le
[Musique]
le second tour des élections municipales
en france avec un taux d'abstention qui
bat des records il pourrait faire date
dans l'histoire
après un premier tour boudé par les
électeurs le 15 mars dernier jamais les
français ne se sont aussi peu déplacé
pour un scrutin local
l'élection de leur mère et pourtant les
mecs y ont préféré des français a
souvent tout avec une protection
sanitaire renforcée dans les bureaux de
vote port du masque obligatoire ou
encore gel hydroalcoolique des règles
sanitaires renforcés pour stopper tout
risque de contamination à mais aussi
pour ne pas reproduire la polémique et
du premier tour sur la propagation du
virus
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france bonsoir
olivier est venu dans cette édition
spéciale ce soir entièrement consacré à
ce second tour des élections municipales
trois mois après le premier tour
et entre temps une crise sanitaire qui a
plombé le pays nous serons en direct
tout au long de la soirée avec nos
reporters sur le terrain
david khalifa à place beauvau devant le
ministère de l'intérieur pour les
chiffres de la participation mona à
mouthe que l'on va retrouver au siège
des républicains au bout de vaugirard à
paris et nous serons également avec
nadège abderrazak tout à l'heure en
province à montpellier au qg du
rassemblement national est là avec nous
également en plateau d'om abonnés
bonsoir thomas on s'en relève du bon
sens magali alors tout au long de la
soirée vous nous donnerez les résultats
et chiffre majeur de ce scrutin
notamment dans les grandes villes mais
tout de suite on va retrouver place
beauvau david khalifa c'est une question
ce soir que les français se posent les
français sont-ils se sont-ils déplacés
pour aller voter si à david khalifa est
cela n'a pas été le cas la participation
est en forte baisse par rapport au
premier tour
effectivement olivier le grand vainqueur
de ce second scrutin à des élections
municipales à 2020 c'est l'abstention
puisque les premières estimations
elle donne ce chiffre 60% d'abstention
un chiffre record pour ce second tour
des élections municipales à savoir qu'il
est en hausse 1 par rapport au 15 mars
dernier le taux d'abstention avait été
de à 55,34 % soit près de 20 points de
plus qu'en 2014
alors cette faible participation
s'explique évidemment par le contexte
sanitaire qui entoure ce vote puisque
les gens en grande partie ne se sont pas
déplacés malgré les mesures renforcées à
de sécurité elles gel hydroalcoolique
parcours fléché port du masque
obligatoire et l'obligation d'avoir son
propre style haut pour ne pas pouvoir
propager le virus en voilà toutes les
mesures qui ont été prises mais
malheureusement ça n'a pas suffi pour
les français et les français qui ont une
certaine forme de désintérêt envers ces
élections
ici pâle puisqu'il un laps de temps
assez conséquents entre le 15 mars
dernier et le 28 juin 2020 7,7 certaine
forme de désintérêt s'est donc traduit à
travers les yeux quelques chiffres à
vous donner notamment à paris et le taux
de participation était légèrement
inférieure à 24% dans la capitale à 17
heures les départements elle les
laissait temps le moins mobilisés elles
sont la scène et saint denis la seine
saint denis
l'ille-et-vilaine le val d'oise et le
val de marne du côté à des dom tom
on approche les 50 5% de participation
sur l'île de la réunion
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que ce second
tour des élections municipales a mis une
question en avant la crise sanitaire a
écrasé les enjeux politiques de ce
second tour des élections municipales
merci beaucoup la vida ville de
californie rect de la place beauvau à
paris on va essayer de comprendre
pourquoi ce taux d'abstention risque de
faire date dans l'histoire avec vous
thomas bonnin quelles sont les raisons a
priori qui ont fait que les français se
sont peu déplacés pour ce scrutin
et bien évidemment il ya les raisons
sanitaires cette crise sanitaire qui a
conduit de nombreux français à ne pas se
déplacer c'était notamment le cas lors
du premier tour de ces élections
municipales où seulement 45 5% des
français avaient voté on assiste donc à
une décrue encore de ce chiffre de la
participation avec vous l'avez entendu
une estimation de 40 % de participation
pour ce second tour c'est évidemment
beaucoup moins que pour les élections
précédentes mais cela en fait est une
comptine une forme de continuité avec
les élections précédentes où le nombre
de participants
nombre d'électeurs qui se rendent aux
urnes étaient en constante diminution
plusieurs explications donc cette crise
sanitaire le fait également que cet
entre deux tours et durer trois mois et
demi peut-être les français n'ont ils
pas été soucieux de se mobiliser pour ce
second tour
alors nous allons tout de suite nous
rendre à perpignan on va écouter
louis
aliot donc perpignan au siège du
rassemblement national où a lieu il ya
quelques minutes qui a revendiqué sa
victoire
il s'apprête donc à prendre la parole en
direct de son qg à perpignan et vous ne
voyez donc sur ces images en direct
louis aliot qui s'apprête à revendiquer
la victoire vous l'avez dit olivier on
va peut-être continuer avant de
l'entendre il attend évidemment que tout
cela soit calé thomas bonnin tout
d'abord on parlait de l'abstention les
seniors aussi c'est une donnée
importante
il est senior qui s'étaient massivement
c'était ma pas massivement déplacés lors
du premier tour selon une estimation de
l'ifop seuls 50% des seniors s'étaient
déplacés pour le premier tour des
élections municipales
c'est une population une tranche d'âge
qui a pour habitude de beaucoup se
mobiliser pour ces élections seules 50%
d'entre donc eux se sont se sont
déplacés au premier tour on verra ce
qu'il en adviendra pour ce second tour
alors du côté des des élus et des
représentants politiques certains
estiment donc que cette que ces
élections municipales pourraient être
impactés de manière très importante par
cette abstention très forte notamment la
démographie qui a été bousculé la
démographie des du corps électoral qui a
été bousculée puisqu'on sait que selon
là encore certaines études les personnes
âgées ont voté majoritairement aux
élections européennes pour des partis
tels que la république en marche ce qui
peut donc expliquer le score assez
faible de du parti de la majorité en
tous cas au premier tour des élections
municipales
merci beaucoup thomas pour toutes ces
précisions alors on vous le disais à
l'instant un lou ye a lieu du
rassemblement national s'apprête à
prendre la parole
on va essayer d'aller retrouver
d'ailleurs tout de suite notre reporter
sur place nadège abderrazak nadège
abderrazak est ce que vous nous entendez
louis aliot s'apprête donc à prendre la
parole
d'ici quelques minutes visiblement
[Musique]
or louis aliot va prendre la parole pour
une prise de parole devant les médias
d'ici une vingtaine de minutes à peu
près il a d'ores et déjà revendiqué la
victoire pour ce second tour des
élections municipales ici à perpignan
d'après les premières estimations le
candidat du parti de marine le pen
remporterait le scrutin avec 53 1% à 54
% face à jean marc pujol et le maire
sortant l est républicain ici dans la
permanence de louis aliot ses soutiens
ont commencé à a exulté tôt à edouard
philippe qui a priori lui aussi a gagné
ce soir ce soir commenter et les
commentateurs auront probablement
beaucoup de beaucoup de travail je leur
souhaite bon courage
mais mais ici voir on est heureux on va
fêter cette victoire on va saluer
l'engagement de tous ceux qui ont été
candidats au havre ou ailleurs et je
voudrais d'ailleurs félicité très
sincèrement mon adversaire jean paul
lecoq
je n'ai pas évidemment d'accord avec ses
convictions mais je les respecte comme
je le respecte lui et je voudrais saluer
tous ceux qui en france se sont engagés
quels que soient leurs idées pour
essayer de les faire valoir
démocratiquement et permettez moi
d'insister sur ce démocratiquement
encore une fois en france les choix sont
faits par ceux qui se déplacent pour
aller voter et ceux qui sont élus
doivent
ensuite avoir la charge de conduire les
affaires publiques mais c'est un élément
important dans une démocratie et il est
bon que intervalles réguliers on puisse
le rappeler merci donc à tous ceux et à
toutes celles qui nous ont fait
confiance et maintenant pour nous au
travail
[Applaudissements]
et donc c'est boire philippe qui vient
de s'exprimer après sa victoire au havre
donc deux informations principales déjà
un taux d'abstention élevé la victoire
d'edouard philippe maillet jouer la
victoire d'étape philippe et on a vu le
qg qui était noire de monde sans pour
autant respecter les distanciation de
rigueur pendant cette crise sanitaire
on va en parler bien sûr ce soir avec
nos invités que l'on vous lui présente
alexis poulain co fondateur du journal
le monde moderne et philippe pascot
écrivain et ancien maire adjoint de
manuel valls à evry bonsoir à tous les
deux merci d'être en direct pour cette
soirée spéciale second tour des
élections municipales alexis poulain une
ré une question pour vous pour commencer
aurait-on dû maintenir en tout cas ce
second tour at-il il a lieu et est ce
une bonne chose selon vous c'est une
bonne chose dans le sens où la vème
république touche à sa fin c'est un
simulacre de démocratie le premier tour
l'a été le deuxième tour l'est encore
plus on peut pas se satisfaire de ce
taux d'abstention c'est pas juste c'est
pas normal c'est pas sain et et on ne
peut pas se satisfaire de disques ou
après les élus vont dire qu'ils ont été
élus que finalement ça fait mais j
timité et qu'on va pouvoir repartir pour
cinq ans un peu comme l'a fait enel
macron lors de son élection en 2017 ça
veut dire qu'on a du mal et avec vous on
va continuer d'en parler avec vous il
semblerait que louis aliot va prendra la
parole dans quelques instants on a pas
que sont pour le moment excusez-moi
alexis poulain je vous laisse poursuivre
donc voilà on peut pas se satisfaire de
ce simulacre de démocratie
tout simplement parce que les gens ne
comprennent pas pourquoi ils votent ne
votent pas l'abstention c'est un mal
profond alors soit on revoit totalement
les modes de scrutin et dans ce cas là
on pourra appeler sa démocratie soit on
arrête tout de suite et on change de
régime mais on ne peut pas avoir un
président qui est élu tous les cinq ans
par défaut avec une base à 25% et qui
fait ce qu'il veut pendant cinq ans
façon roi soleil miniature donc ça ne
satisfait pas la majorité des français
je pense alors ça satisfait les fans de
celui qui est élu
mais on voit bien qu'il ya un malaise
profond dans notre pays que ce soit
gilet jaune depuis deux ans les
manifestations soignant les policiers
maintenant les professeurs et tous les
autres qui sont dans la rue pour dire ça
suffit
en fait nous souhaiterions être entendu
le grand débat était un simulacre ces
municipales sont encore un simulacre
bravo à ceux qui ont été élus mais
malheureusement on ne peut pas appeler
ça des élections enfin c'est pour moi
une dernier théâtre d'un régime qui
atteint le bout de souffle et c'est pas
pour rien que les gilets jaunes
demandaient le référendum d'initiative
citoyenne qu' il y avait une volonté en
fait il ya une envie dans ce pays de
réhabiliter la démocratie le
gouvernement du peuple par le peuple
pour le peuple de refaire république
autrement et je crois que si on continue
comme ça c'est deux ans de fin de mandat
d'aider m'hamed macron vont être
extrêmement pénible extrêmement longues
à remaniement avec à nouveau des
artistes capables de dire tout et
n'importe quoi pour avoir un poste de
ministre des voiles à ces élections
municipales qui sont alors c'est évident
c'est pas la faute à personne mais
fallait-il les maintenir
je pense que compte tenu de ce qui a été
le premier tour s'était pas forcément
une bonne idée mais il fallait bien sûr
mettre des collèges municipaux avoir de
deux nouvelles équipes pour faire
avancer les villes et les territoires
est ce que c'est la bonne façon de faire
ça permet de masquer aussi une gifle
électorale massive pour la majorité qui
est balayée dans ces municipales sa
fausse complètement tout d'une certaine
façon et mais c'est une sortie facile
pour éviter de dire que abbaoui s'y
aligner ce musée a perdu à paris c'est
pas de sa faute c'est le co vide et si
la majorité se pointe claque c'est pas
de sa faute non plus mais je crois que
ce simulacre là moi me commence à me
fatiguer en tant que commentateur en
tant que lecteur en tant que citoyen
tout simplement j'ai envie d'autre chose
je pense que à partir du moment où on en
arrive là
avec un taux de participation si faible
il faut revoir totalement la façon dont
on fait les scrutins la façon dont on
engage aussi des campagnes cette
campagne elle n'a pas eu lieu
c'était une campagne fantôme on ne
pouvait pas faire campagne avec ou sans
les masques enfin c'est impossible en
fait deux
by lisez et des équipes et les gens
alors les équipes se sont mobilisées
bravo à ceux qui ont été élus bravo à
tous ceux qui ont fait le travail mais
honnêtement je ne vois pas comment on
peut se satisfaire d'être élue ce soir
dans des conditions pareilles merci à
alexis poulain je rappelle que vous êtes
co fondateur du journal le monde moderne
avec nous également philippe que parce
qu écrivait ancien maire-adjoint de
manuel valls à evry
on a entendu il ya quelques minutes
edouard philippe
sa victoire n'était pas forcément
acquise
est-ce que selon vous il a profité de sa
bonne gestion de la crise pendant cette
la crise du coc vide non je crois pas il
a profité comme le disait alexis du taux
d'abstention énorme qu'il ya eu sur ces
élections je rappelle quand même que
c'est un un simulacre de fou on n'est
même plus dans une démocratie
comment ces gens là peuvent dire qu'ils
ont été élus démocratiquement avec
quasiment un électeur sur dix un
électeur se et je trouve ça vachement
marrant parce que si ça se trouve les
bulletins de vote n'ont pas fini d'être
contée est déjà à 20 heures ces gens là
aussi bien au havre qu'à perpignan
commence à pérorer je suis d'accord avec
elle et xia brive faire que ça s'arrête
c'est plus possible ces gens là se
gratte le nombril en se disant je suis
élu alors qu'ils sont juste élu parce
que leur mère leurs soeurs et leurs
petits camarades ont voté pour eux
l'ensemble de la population n'a pas été
votée et contrairement à ce que disait
thomas tout à l'heure c'est pas
forcément à cause du coc vide
moi j'ai plein de gens autour de moi
qu'on pas été bottées parce que ils
savaient plus pour qui voter il n'avait
pas envie de voter ni pour la paix est
dit paul cola ces élections aujourd'hui
telle que ces faits la démocratie telle
qu'elle est définie par ses propres gens
tous partis dominants confondues n'est
plus une démocratie c'est juste un
simulacre de vote pour asseoir des
barons locaux dans des endroits où ils
font du clientélisme
parce que l'élection municipale de la
plupart de ses élus et uniquement basée
sur du clientélisme ses débuts de la
démocratie si philippe pascot vous
restez bien entendu avec nous et on va
continuer on va prendre la direction
tout de suite de perpignan pour
retrouver notre reporter nadège
abderrazak au quartier général du
rassemblement national
louis aliot a revendiqué sa victoire ce
soir un petit peu avant 20h d'ailleurs
m'a déjà des razak louis aliot qui va
prendre la parole dans quelques instants
oui c'est ça hein magali 1 d'après les
premières estimations louis aliot
remporterait en effet le second tour des
élections municipales avec 53,1 % à 54 %
face au maire sortant jean marc pujol
ici dans la permanence de louis aliot
ses soutiens ont commencé a exulté à
célébrer est la victoire croft trente
minutes avant l'annoncé des premières
estimations puisque certains des
certaines des estimations avaient
commencé à fuiter la troisième
participation a donc été la bonne pour
le candidat du parti de marine le pen
qui avait échoué en 2014 je passe au
même adversaire et après et avant une
participation une première participation
en 2008 c'est un gros coup pour le
rassemblement national pourquoi et bien
parce que c'est la première grande ville
que décroche le rassemblement national
après toulon et 1995 on le rappelle
perpignan c'est une ville de 120 mille
habitants elle louis aliot devrait donc
s'exprimer d'ici une vingtaine de
minutes à peu près et on va suivre cela
bien sûr avec vous n'a déjà des razak
louis aliot à perpignan donc qui
sembleraient remporte la victoire ce
soir alors qu'un front républicain
s'était constitué dans cette ville
justement pour lui faire barrage vous
aliot qui était arrivé en tête au
premier tour et donc qui remporte ray
cette élection ce soir et emmanuel
macron qui s'est exprimé il y à quelques
instants thomas l'elysée indique que et
madame à contredire est préoccupé par le
faible taux de participation aux
municipales il faut dire qu'on n'a pas
encore le chiffre exact de la
participation mais on serait au tour des
40% c'est cinq points de moins 5 points
de moins que
le premier tour alors effectivement le
premier tour on l'a dit avait été
impacté par la crise sanitaire les
conditions qui sont un peu meilleures
pour ce second tour et pourtant la
participation est en baisse
cela veut bien dire et vos invités l'ont
dit qu'il ya aussi une forme de
désintérêt de la part des électeurs pour
ces élections municipales un désintérêt
qui était déjà marqué depuis les
dernières élections cela fait des années
que la participation se réduit à mesure
que les élections municipales
s'enchaînent on a donc là une
confirmation il ya beaucoup d'élus qui
après les résultats du premier tour
avait parlé d'un résultat faussé et
certains même conteste la légitimité du
scrutin par rapport au très faible taux
de participation qui semble encore se
dessiner ce soir merci thomas et on va
prendre à présent la direction du
quartier général les républicains pour
rejoindre notre reporter sur place mona
amoud et l'or mona quelle est l'ambiance
de votre côté on a vu déjà à perpignan
les républicains qui se sont vu ravir la
place ce soir par le rassemblement
national
eh bien écoutez le qg des républicains
est quasiment vide personne aucun député
année présents sur place
on m'a pas encore également les chiffres
concernant rachida dati ou encore anne
hidalgo tout ce qu'on sait c'est que ce
taux de participation à paris était de
23 à 20 89% contre 38,60 % en 2014 une
très forte baisse mais attention elle
ces chiffres sont susceptibles de
changer tout au long de la soirée on a
également une abstention historique qui
devrait être aux alentours de 50 9% et
aux maladies le président la république
a dit être préoccupé de ce faible taux
de participation rachida dati elle
incarne un petit peu la candidate de
l'espoir pour la droite elle qui
estimait être la mieux placée est la
plus déterminée à gagner est la mairie
de paris
propreté sécurité ou encore la relance
économiques étaient au coeur
de sa campagne à elle ces municipales
elles sont également l'occasion d'être
un rebond politique pour les
républicains après plusieurs jets ses
échecs pardon notamment aux
présidentielles ou encore aux
européennes
néanmoins en province le premier tour a
été assez gratifiant pour les petites
républicaines qui ont pu conserver
quelques villes parfois avec des
alliances avec la république en marche
au premier tour le parti avait
revendiqué avoir remporté seuls 30% de
villes de plus de 9000 habitants au
premier tour et 56% avec ses alliés
quelques maires sortants étaient déjà
réélu au premier tour comme françois
baroin à 3 arnaud robinet à reims ou
encore natacha bouchart à cap akalé
l'ambition était de continuer sur cette
voie ce sont elles les mots de christian
jacot christian jacob qui prendra la
parole aux alentours de 21h30 22h ici
même à paris dans le xvème et on va sur
eux cela bien sûr merci beaucoup m'ont
hamoud en direct du quartier général à l
est républicain dans le 15e
arrondissement à paris et thomas ce
résultat qui vient de tomber à lille
martine aubry devancé de peu par le
candidat à picot logis où on va rester
très prudent puisque le dépouillement
n'est pas encore tout à fait terminé
mais c'est vrai que selon les premières
estimations martine aubry serait devancé
de très peu par le candidat donc
écologistes alors cette une c'est un
désaveu c'était une grosse défaite pour
martine aubry qui devait qui compte qu'à
concouraient pour un quatrième mandat
lettre est arrivée en tête des suffrages
au premier tour avec 29 81% et elle
avait décliné une fusion de sa liste
avec celle des écologistes prenant donc
le risque d'autres d'être rattrapé au
second tour c'est ce qui semble être le
cas ce soir mais on va encore une fois
rester assez prudent puisque les camps
les résultats définitifs pardon ne sont
pas encore tout à fait complet puisqu'il
est le dépouillement n'est pas terminée
dans la ville de lille merci thomas vous
restez bien évidemment avec nous pour
réactualiser des chiffres tout au long
de la soirée et on en parle de ce second
tour des élections municipales ont
rejoint alexis poulain à distance bien
sûr puisque on respecte ici sur l'artère
france les règles sanitaires
est ce que pour vous
cette élection avec six poulains s'est
bien déroulé on a vu les français et les
bureaux de vote qui avaient misé en
place des mesures pour éviter justement
toute contamination
le premier tour a eu son lot de
contamination sont selon les
spécialistes ce second tour finalement
selon vous comme d'ailleurs le
rassemblement national où la rue
lafrance insoumise il avait dit qu'il ne
fallait pas qu'il y ait ce second tour
que les élections devaient être
reportées c'est donc votre avis ce soir
oui je crois de toute participation du
tout et l'hypocrisie de ceux qui se
plaignent qu'ils versent des larmes de
crocodile en disant qu'il y à 60% de
deux d'abstention dit tous c'est un
calcul politique qui permet à la
majorité deux maquillés en fait la
claque électorale massive qui est donnée
à la république en marche qui n'existe
pas dans ces élections à part quelques
stars du parti et déjà reçu au premier
tour avec six poulains cette claque dont
vous parlez mais ça permet pas de dire
oui la campagne a été compliqué et puis
c'est la faute au virus s'est pas c'est
pas simplement parce que les gens ne
veulent plus les voir donc tout ça vous
allez avoir des commentateurs politiques
des élus qui vont être capables de dire
des choses de cet acabit
donc il ya un calcul politique réelle
qui est celui de tenir le calendrier des
élections pour et bien essayer d'avoir
le sénat essayer de faire avancer aussi
un calendrier électoral de préparer 2022
dès à présent ces municipales simulacre
d'élections comme philippe et moi
l'avons dit nous sommes d'accord c'est
simplement la préparation du simulacre
prochain de 2022
c'est pour moi c'est hors de question de
rejouer
marine le pen est mené le maquereau en
2022 ça voudrait dire que la démocratie
est morte dans ce pays iliad il ya des
oppositions
il ya des idées il ya des courants
démocratiques fort il ya une diversité
démocratique mais vraiment importante en
france qui ne peut pas s'exprimer
simplement parce que les institutions
sont ce qu'elles sont vous avez ce
simulacre d'élection qui satisfait à
ceux qui en profitent depuis des années
ceux qui sont élus ce qu'ils savent
qu'ils peuvent embellir
ici et derrière c'est beaucoup d'argent
du financement de parti c'est des
baronnies locales
cette organisation c'est du clientélisme
comme philippe l'a dit mais ça ne me
satisfait pas en tant que citoyen ça ne
devrait satisfaire aucun français ce
soir ce qu'on a vu là c'est long terme
en grande pompe de la vème république et
je ne pense pas que ça peut continuer
deux ans comme ça ça me paraît compliqué
ça va être extrêmement pénible et et
l'hypocrisie telle qu'elle est présentée
aujourd'hui est dangereuse parce que la
fin de la démocratie c'est tout
simplement l'avènement d'un régime
autoritaire si on continue avec ces gens
là il faut revivifier la démocratie avec
les gens qui le veulent je crois
qu'aujourd'hui la question de la sixième
république se pose la question des
scrutins se pose je pense pas qu'on peut
valider des scrutins quand l'abstention
est plus forte que le taux de
participation il faut revoir les règles
qui sont écrites dans la constitution
aujourd'hui on ne peut pas se contenter
de ce2 de ce théâtre qui n'a rien à voir
avec avec ce que devrait être la
république française
alors philippe pascot je me tourne vers
vous une campagne pour le second tour
uniquement sur les réseaux sociaux et
dans les médias est ce que cela a pu
jouer est ce qu'elle a manqué la fameuse
poignée de main sur les marchés non mais
non elle n'a pas manqué de tous les
genres des gens faut arrêter de prendre
les gens pour des cons moi ce qui
m'amuse beaucoup ce soir c'est
d'entendre pépère macro dire qu'il est
seulement préoccupés mais il ya eu un
électeur sur dix qui a été voté pour le
candidat vainqueur et dans sept
électeurs sur dix ils ont eu en marche a
pris une claque phénoménale et tout ce
que dit monsieur macron c'est qu'il est
préoccupé
ça prouve une fois plus que ces gens là
ne sont plus en phase avec la société ne
sont plus chez nous il ya une fracture
entre eux et nous le peuple aujourd'hui
n'est pas la même chose que les
représentants le peuple aujourd'hui ne
représente pas les élus monsieur macro
et juste préoccuper le peuple ne s'est
pas déplacé pour voter mais il faut
absolument qu'ils fassent qui remettent
un masque sur sa tête qu'ils les
trouvent les masques ou tu dis moi qu'il
l'enlève pour regarder la réalité du
terrain
moi je rejoins lexie aujourd'hui nous y
sommes
dans une démocratie nous sommes dans une
société qui petit à petit se dirige vers
une dictature quand je vois et vous me
confirmer que ya des candidats qui n'ont
même pas fini de compter les bulletins
et qu'ils passent devant la télé pour
dire je suis élu mais c'est un manque de
respect total par rapport aux électeurs
non seulement il ya eu très peu
d'électeurs qui se sont déplacés mais on
n'a même pas fini d'annoncer des
bulletins qu'on commence à faire le beau
à la télé mais c'est quoi cette
démocratie c'est juste une démocratie de
communication c'est juste une démocratie
de clientélisme
c'est juste une démocratie qui sert les
intérêts de quelques-uns de plus en plus
le peuple est mis sur le côté
de plus et le peuple malheureusement n'a
pas encore compris qu'il est le nombre
n'a pas encore compris que les patrons
c'est nous c'est pas eu pour l'instant
on au plie encore les chine
et puis comme de toute manière on sait
pas où se trouvait et bien
malheureusement on va pas voter mais moi
je vous rejoins totalement alexis quand
vous avez 60 % et je rappelle que les
60% n'est qu'un chiffre pondérer c'est à
dire qu on fait la moyenne de tous les
endroits et par exemple en corse il ya
eu 71 % de votants c'est vrai que la
corse a la particularité d'arriver à
faire voter même les gens de 110 ans
donc ça veut dire qu'il ya des endroits
où il ya eu plus de 70 80 % de gens qui
ne se sont pas déplacés pour voter
comment on peut encore dire que c'est
une élection
comment ces gens là aux dires mais
alexis le disait très bien quand vous
grattez un petit peu il ya plein de
barons locaux qui trouvent leur compte
quand je vois des vieux chevaux de
bataille qui se représentent et qui sont
élus c'est pas il n'y a pas un président
comment il s'appelle d'ailleurs ça
commence par un m
il a été élu remis en mai 2010 est
qu'ils nous disaient qu'ils allaient
moraliser la vie politique et j'entends
des élus qui se représente pour la
quatrième fois pour la cinquième fois à
l'est où cette moralisation aller où
cette loi qui disait qu'on peut pas se
présenter plus de trois mandats
ces gens-là nous mentent et maintenant
ils nous mentent officiellement il nous
montre encore en liste oui philippe on
sait de qui vous parlez d'ailleurs on va
le regarder le président de la
république qui a voté ce matin au
touquet où nous
vous voyez ces images avec nous et
emmanuel macron qui s'est rendu aux
urnes avec son épouse au touquet
brigitte macron qui possède une maison
en plein centre du touquet on le voit
donc on va le voir d'ailleurs sur ces
images le couple macron qui a voté
protéger le président qui avait un
masque avec une visière également les
images vont les voici
ça c'est à la sortie mais emmanuel
macron qui a enlevé son masque
d'ailleurs pour prendre un bain de foule
il ya une certaine incohérence dans les
gestes barrière alexis poulain on avait
vu le président de la république au
premier tour pas masquer d'ailleurs est
là bien barricader derrière une visière
et un masque qu'en pensez vous écoutez
il est surtout barricader derrière son
service de sécurité et puis c'est une
mise en scène comme d'hab youtube donc
il fallait profiter des photos faire un
bain de foule ça aurait été dommage de
les gâcher avec un masque parce que
c'est rare et moselle mc on soit à
clapet paru ou le même si elle est comme
ça organisée au touquet où il a sa
maison qui lui a d'ailleurs permis de
faire de l'optimisation fiscale
on n'a pas fini de tout savoir sur cette
maison de brigitte mâcon et c'est très
drôle de voir ça parce qu'évidemment lui
comme edouard philippe ne met pas de
masque parce que c'est important de se
montrer au milieu d'une foule plutôt
aimante parce que c'est rare pour eux
donc il faut pas se priver de ce moment
de propagande c'est extrêmement
important dans un régime à bout de
souffle donc bon bah c'est ça fait
partie des règles de ce jeu je trouve
triste à voir parce que on est vraiment
à dans une hypocrisie dans une mise en
scène totale et dans la fin d'un régime
on ne peut pas se satisfaire je suis
désolée de ce taux d'abstention et
sanasa n'amènerait ça n'augure rien de
bon pour les prochains scrutins
alors philippe pascot vous parliez tout
à l'heure de communication justement on
a vu le président de la république voté
avec un masque tout comme edouard
philippe
cependant le confinement souvient aussi
de ces images du président de la
république mais cette fois sans masque
prendre des bains de foule des erreurs
de communication l'aveu selon vous alors
messei fait du madoff
en ce moment ils sont dans la panique la
plus totale et ils font du n'importe
quoi d'ailleurs la plupart des images de
communication de ban foule que vous voit
à travers des images qui sont dirigés
quand on retrouve ces mêmes images sur
les réseaux sociaux
mais au plan large et on s'aperçoit que
la foule n'est pas nombreuses
je me rappelle d'une fois où il s'est
dirigé vers des gens vers une barrières
vauban en plan serré on avait
l'impression qu'il y avait 200 personnes
en plein en large il était que 50 c'est
la panique totale à l'elysée il se dit
préoccupé mais les staff autour de macro
sont complètement perdus qui font
n'importe quoi et on l'a bien vu comme
sur la façon dont ils ont géré la crise
due comme id un coup les masques a coulé
masquer un coup pas les mascaras
aujourd'hui il ya eu une élection
municipale qui s'est passé les gens qui
sont élus ne sont plus représentatifs de
la population issue côte est élu le le
pari des républiques en marche c'est
parce qu c'était de d'avoir dix mille
représentants locaux stanislas guérini
affirme qu'il y en a eu six mille au 1er
tour vous n'êtes pas d'accord
le pari de la république en marche et
d'avoir ses 500 élus pour pouvoir se
présenter à l'élection présidentielle
je vous dirais que dix mille élus il les
a pas par contre c'est sûr qu'il aura
ses petits 500 élus parce que comme il
distribue des pièces et des piécettes
com heureusement pour la france entre
guillemets il ya un an je sais même pas
où on peut dire heureusement on va
changer de premier ministre bientôt je
sais pas si c'est un bien chez pastia
mal mais j'arrive pas à comprendre que
le premier que le premier ministre par
exemple se présentent au havre et que
s'il reste premier ministre il va quand
même resté maire il va démissionner
c'est quoi ces gens là on est totalement
dans notre monde de l'apparence on est
totalement dans un monde où il nous
montre des choses et il faut la verse et
je dis bien ils font la verse
ces élections municipales aujourd'hui en
marche les a complètement war est en
marche
et comme ils vont voir et la plupart des
autres élections ils vont maintenant
inventer des systèmes où vous allez voir
bientôt ils vont nous proposer le vote
électronique ça évitera aux gens de se
déplacer
merci louis parce que vous restez
philippe pascot pardon vous restez
avec nous en direct sur rt france on va
aller tout de suite prendre la direction
du que j'ai du rassemblement national à
perpignan on va retrouver notre envoyé
spécial nadège abderrazak louis aliot a
revendiqué sa victoire peu avant 20
heures
oui c'est ça olivier il a revendiqué sa
victoire il devrait s'exprimer d'ici une
poignée de minutes maintenant
d'après les dernières estimations il
remporterait le scrutin avec 53 de la
bulle 1% à 54 % des voix face à jean
marc pujol maire sortant les
républicains ici dans son qg de campagne
rue mailly dans le centre-ville de
perpignan les soutiens ont d'ores et
déjà et bien commencé a exulté à
célébrer cette victoire 30 minutes avant
l annonce des premières estimations la
troisième participation de louis aliot
aura donc été la bonne après avoir
échoué en 2014 face à ce même adversaire
et avant une première participation en
2008 alors c'est un gros coup pour le
rassemblement national qui décroche la
plus grande ville depuis toulon en 1995
on le rappelle perpignan c'est 120 mille
habitants alors on a tenté de faire
barrage au rassemblement national
notamment vis-à-vis par rapport à 1
un front républicain mise en place et
proposé de l'écologiste agnès langevine
et de romain grau candidats lrm un front
républicain qui a donc échoué ce soir et
qui a été qualifié d'escroquerie
mentales et intellectuelles par le
nouveau maire élu donc de perpignan
louis aliot le nouveau maire devrait
donc et bien s'adresser je le disais
d'ici une poignée de minutes ici dans
son qg de campagne rue mailly avant une
fête une célébration ce soir dans la
nuit la place aragon
merci beaucoup un adage nadège de razac
qu'on va retrouver tout au long de la
soirée en direct du qg du rassemblement
national à perpignan alexis poule à une
question justement sur cette victoire du
rassemblement à perpignan c'est une
ville moyenne c'est une victoire notable
même si le rassemblement national n'a
pas vraiment marqué deux points au
premier tour on l'a vu il a conservé les
villes classique plus ou moins ce front
républicain il a volé en éclats comment
l'expliquez vous c'était pas vraiment un
front républicain vous avez une alliance
d'intérêts en fait entre des écolos aux
et le parti majoritaire qui savaient
qu'ils allaient droite à la perte donc
c'est normal finalement parce qu'il n'y
avait pas de structure réelle c'était un
intérêt pour marine le pen prend la
parole en direct priorité au direct on
va écouter la chef du rassemblement
national à présent ça ne contredit pas
votre ligne ni droite ni gauche sachant
plus est plus proche d'une droite
classique
non je ne crois pas du tout en
l'occurrence je pense que beaucoup de
gens ont voté pour lui à llo y compris
d'ailleurs des gens qui venaient de la
gauche il avait d'ailleurs sur sa liste
les gens qui venaient de la gauche il
avait également des personnes qui étend
sur d'autres listes avaient appelé à
voter pour lui au second tour non je
crois que c'est vraiment la victoire du
rassemblement des français autour d'un
projet autour d'une équipe autour d'une
ville qui il faut bien le dire concentre
l'ensemble des échecs de la politique
menée par les dirigeants français depuis
des années
l'insécurité la division le chômage
l'effondrement économique c'est à tout
cela que louer son équipe vont devoir
répondre maintenant et ils le font j'en
suis sûr avec beaucoup de sérieux
beaucoup de pugnacité beaucoup de
compétences qu'est-ce que vous inspire
la victoire d'edouard philippe au havre
et pour la suite de la politique ça
c'est à lui de
décidée il est sûr que il était dans une
situation où il aurait il aurait été
étonnant qu'il ne soit pas élu
c'est d'ailleurs quasiment si je puis me
permettre la seule victoire dans marche
véritablement puisque dans toutes les
autres villes il faut bien le dire
la moisson de grandes villes qu'espérait
le mouvement en marche n'a pas donné de
résultats très très flagrant alors
attendons de voir si le premier ministre
soit resté premier ministre ou s'il
souhaite devenir maire de toute façon ça
changera pas grand chose à la politique
menée par emmanuel macron et voilà donc
pour lindt herviou de marine le pen ce
soir qui a réagi en direct à la victoire
d'edouard philippe au havre et à la
victoire du rassemblement national bien
sûr à perpignan je continue avec vous à
alexis pourrait on parler de ce front
républicain qui a volé en éclats marine
le pen on vient d'entendre son félicite
elle dit que c'est la victoire
finalement de tout ce qui va pas en
france selon l un à l'insécurité
l'immigration ça a payé
ce sont des thèmes wii qui paye
c'est d'ailleurs les thèmes qui font que
le front national on est là aujourd'hui
le rassemblement national on est là
aujourd'hui
peu importe les affaires celle-ci
finalement n'existe pas pour les
électeurs alors que c'est un parti quand
même qui sort à peine d'un jugement
assez catastrophique mais le fait est
que le mécontentement avec les partis
existants est telle que pour le
rassemblement national il suffit de ne
rien faire que d'exister pour bien pour
simplement dire essayer nous parce que
vous verrez ça ne veut pas dire que
l'essai sera concluant une grande ville
comme perpignan on verra à ce que ce qui
amènera la pratique du pouvoir mais
c'est quelque chose de grave parce qu'on
ne peut pas se contenter en fait d'avoir
ce parti le rassemblement national comme
seul opposant face à le candidat que
sera celui de 2022 parce que le calcul
des manuels mccraw est simple il veut
refaire 2017 il veut se représenter et
avoir face à lui une marine le pen parce
qu'il sait que au final au national avec
une
campagne dans les médias avec la façon
dont on peut faire il pourrait peut-être
passé pas cette fois-ci peut-être qu'en
2022 ce sera tout à fait différent mais
c'est dangereux parce que sur leur
assemblée nationale aujourd'hui
comme vous l'avez dit il n'y a pas eu
non plus de grandes vagues sur les
villes alors perpignan c'est un incident
mais c'est la troisième fois que lui
aliot essayait c'est dans un contexte
régional et leur assemblée nationale un
discours très différents en fonction des
territoires
le discours du nord et du sud n'est pas
du tout de même vous aurez un discours
beaucoup plus sociale au nord un
discours beaucoup plus anti immigration
liste au sud
c'est un parti protéiforme qui justement
permet d'engranger des voix de cette
façon là c'est normal
marine le pen sourit elle sait qu'elle a
un boulevard maintenant devant réel
parce que si on continue dans cette voie
là la démocratie réelle n'ira pas bien
loin en fait dans ce simulacre et elle a
toutes ses chances en 2022
quoiqu'en pense robert ménard parce que
le mécontentement avec ce président
macron est totale parce que cette
hypocrisie à arriver à son terme et
parce que les autres oppositions
finalement n'ont pas la place médiatique
qu'elle qu'elle mériterait
ou simplement n'arrive pas à se fédérer
comme le disait philippe pasqua
aujourd'hui il ya plein de citoyens de
bonne volonté qui ont envie de faire
autre chose qui auront dit de faire
revivre cette démocratie française
autrement mais qui n'en n'ont pas les
moyens
ça demande beaucoup d'énergie beaucoup
de temps beaucoup d'argent aussi de
faire un parti politique
or là le scrutin présidentiel n'est que
dans deux ans donc c'est extrêmement
extrêmement complexe et est compliqué et
ça paraît très simple pour marine le pen
alors philippe pascot je me tourne vers
vous cette réaction là quelques minutes
de jordan bardella du rassemblement
national
il s'est félicité d'avoir fait voler en
éclats le front républicain le front
républicain qui apparaissait pour
beaucoup comme une évidence c'est fini
alexis l'a dit c'est pas des frauds
républicain cd from clientélisme c'est
souvent l'alliance de la carpe et du
lapin
et puis les gens ne sont pas de moyens
dans le piège vous vous rendez compte
qu'à lille martine aubry s'est pas rendu
compte qu'en étant soutenu par un parti
de
soit elles allaient directement dans le
mur ces gens là sont encore dans un
autre monde
non le front républicain il n'existe pas
moi ce que j'aimerais que carré d'as
créé ces affronts de citoyens et c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui
rappelez vous écoutez bien ce que je lis
sur le 28 juin 2020 ocon grande
formation politique n'a dit qu'il
fallait repousser le bulletin à le
repousser le vote à cause du coc vide
parce que quelque part tous ces gens là
tous ces vieux politicards tous ces
vieux routard de la politique ça les
arrangeait qu'on continue à voir les
élections il savait déjà qu'il y aurait
un tripot taux d'abstention est que
grâce à ce très haut taux d'abstention
celui qui était un petit peu connu sur
sur le terrain celui qui était un vieux
cheval de retour et est quasiment sûre
d'être élu quand vous voyez qu'il ya des
monsieur copé monsieur copé qui a été
élu au premier tour
pourquoi c'est la prime au sortant ces
élections municipales c'est ce que nous
essayons c'est toujours la prime aux
sortants et en plus quand vous faites du
clientélisme comme ces gens là le fond
eh ben ils sont élus quand il ya très
peu d'électeurs vous rendez compte que
je lui ai des endroits où il ya eu 80 %
de gens qui n'ont pas été votées et il y
avait quatre candidats au deuxième tour
ces gens là ont beau être élu avec 1,2
me électeurs sur 10 1/2 électeurs
soliste mais c'est un bonheur d'être élu
de faire des élections
d'ailleurs ils pensent vraiment à les
supprimer parce que à ce tarif là si ça
continue ils vont juste est élu avec
trois électeurs mais ça les arrange
parce qu'ils ne veulent pas pourquoi
monsieur maquereau a refusé de mettre le
bulletin blanc comme à bulletins
exprimés alors que c'était une demande
de 90% de la population
il y aurait peut-être eu un peu plus de
gens qu aller voter mais il vole pas il
préfère dire comme a déclaré tout à
l'heure mais si edouard philippe que si
vous n'allez pas voter c'est bien fait
pour vos pieds
mais il faut savoir que tous ces gens là
je dis bien tous ces gens là organisent
et sont d'accord ok de moins en moins de
gens qui aillent voter c'est malheureux
les gens suivent et on va tout de suite
prendre la direction de perpignan merci
beaucoup un flipper ce qu on prend la
direction de perpignan
ou justement loeb vainqueur ce soir
s'exprime il s'agit bien sûr de louis
aliot qui a gagné cette élection ce soir
mesdames et messieurs je ne vais pas
être très long je me réserve évidemment
pour des déclarations ultérieures
mettez-vous de chaque côté mesdames
messieurs mes chers amis perpignanaise
les perpignanais c'est avec une très
grande émotion que je m'adresse à vous
ce soir et que je m'adresse à toutes
celles et ceux qui ont contribué à
démolir le mur de l'injustice le mur des
inégalités et le mur du mensonge c'est
une grande fierté pour toute la ville et
tous ceux qui m'ont apporté leur
suffrage
parce que l'anathème la diffamation et
tout ce qui va avec n'ont que trop duré
à perpignan comme partout en france
il y à des citoyens libres il y à des
hommes libres et je tenais évidemment ce
soir a salué un certain nombre tout
d'abord mes colistiers qui m'ont
accompagné durant toute cette aventure
et qui contre vents et marées ont
toujours été droit courageux sur le
terrain à l'ecoute est désormais
mobilisée à redonner à perpignan ses
lettres de noblesse au militant
exemplaire
qui ont tracté qui ont emboîté qui ont
collé qui sont encore en ce moment dans
les bureaux de vote et qu'ils méritent
l'ensemble de mes félicitations
tellement ils ont été à la hauteur de la
victoire un message aussi aux candidats
des autres listes ou même aux autres
candidats que le courage de ne pas
tomber dans le piège du retrait
républicain ou de l'abominable front dit
républicain et qui se sont comportés
comme des hommes libres dans une
démocratie qui devrait l'être et fidèle
aux valeurs de notre république de
liberté d'égalité et de fraternité
nous allons enfin pouvoir travailler à
perpignan pouvoir travailler à une ville
plus juste une vie le plus sûr une ville
plus prospère nous allons enfin pouvoir
travailler à la démocratie et à
l'approfondissement de la démocratie à
défendre les véritables valeurs de la
république notamment dans les quartiers
où on a laissé trop longtemps des jambes
dans la misère et dans l'injustice et
qu'on a tenté encore une fois de
soudoyer à ces élections
alors qui sont les premières victimes du
système qui avait en place à perpignan
je le dis très clairement dès cette
semaine j'annoncerai qu'elles seront
celles et ceux qui m'accompagneront à la
mairie dans les différentes
responsabilités et y envoyer un message
de fraternité de soutien de solidarité à
tous les employés de la mairie qu'il ne
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ne s'inquiète de rien et ils verront que
les véritables démocrates les véritables
défenseurs du pluralisme politique de la
liberté de choix de la liberté d opinion
ceux qui défendront les valeurs du
travail
les valeurs de l'ancienneté les valeurs
de l'égalité
et bien aujourd'hui sont aux commandes
de la mairie
contrairement à ce qu'ils avaient connue
pendant longtemps je tenais évidemment à
remercier encore une fois les
perpignanaises et les perpignanais car
la page qu'ils viennent de tourner à
perpignan a valeur de symbole pour la
france entière
il n'y a pas un sûrs au monde qui depuis
se tombait et celui de perpignan ce soir
était un mur qui durait depuis trop
longtemps mais j'appelle évidemment
celles et ceux qui en france en ce
jardin barrages dans leurs villes dans
leur département ou dans leur région et
bien a participé à la conquête pour
l'avenir car je pense que la france doit
avoir aussi un message d'espoir pour
tous ses habitants tous ses citoyens et
que dans cette reconquête perpignan aura
toute sa place
je remercie vraiment du fond du coeur
toutes celles qui ont osé parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est d'abord la victoire
du peuple de perpignan merci
[Applaudissements]
et voilà donc le discours de louis aliot
qui a priori le remporteront porte la
mairie ce soir avec 53% des suffrages et
une forte abstention on le rappelle
olivier et des nouveaux chiffres
thomas notamment qui concerne la ville
de mulhouse fortement touché par la
crise sanitaire dans le grand est mais
également aliot absolument prime aux
sortants vous en parliez tout à l'heure
avec vos invités bien cela semble être
le cas à mulhouse ville on la dit très
fortement touché un des premiers foyers
de contamination du colis de 19 en
france
michel lutz candidate les républicains
en lice donc pour sa réélection serait
en tête avec 38,78 voix prime au sortant
également à à pau où françois bayrou
serait là aussi réélue en revanche donc
c'est plus compliqué pour martine aubry
il s'agit encore d'estimation
dépouillement n'est pas tout à fait
terminé mais martine aubry la maire
socialiste de la ville de lille serait
devancé de peu par son concurrent
d'europe écologie les verts on attend
encore la confirmation de ces résultats
et puis estimation à lyon également où
se seraient grégory doucet le candidat
écologiste qui serait là également en
tête selon les premières estimations
dans la ville de lyon il y avait une
division entre les candidats de la
réplique république en marche puisque
officiellement et yann cucherat était
intronisé comme le candidat de la
majorité mais un candidat dissident
s'était maintenu au second tour ce qui
peut expliquer ces premières estimations
qui nous parviennent il s'agirait donc
d'une défaite pour la république en
marche qui vise en tout cas qui visait
la ville les villes de lyon et de paris
ça semble un petit peu se complique et
d'ailleurs si bête ndiaye la porte
parole du gouvernement explique ce soir
nous éprouvons une déception à merci
thomas et on va en parler avec nos
invités alexis poulain on a écouté
thomas bonnet avec ses résultats a
priori qui ne sont pas encore définitifs
mais les écologistes semblent tirer leur
épingle du jeu de ce scrutin on l'a déjà
vu au premier tour or on constate les
alliances qui ont été faites dans
différentes
c'est surtout la république en marche et
la droite qui n'est pas franchement
écolo bien sûr non mais c'est parce que
c'est l'idée c'est d'avoir des déplacés
de gagner des sièges
peu importe la couleur des alliés alors
après il ya effectivement cette mise en
scène du front républicain qui permet
non sur le coeur de jurer sur les grands
principes mais la réalité est bien
différente
c'est une énorme claque pour la
république en marche ce n'est pas une
surprise puisque le premier tour avaient
déjà montré que c'était le cas c'est
surprenant enfin vous avez eu aussi
edouard philippe qui lors de son ultime
vous l'avez montré tout à l'heure on
entendait quand même en font un des
petits manifestants scandaient même si
mac on le veut pas on est là je crois
que je n'étais pas très serein à la
tribune
donc tous ces gens sont élus à 50 et
quelques c'est pas des plébiscites non
plus on arrive quand même avec des gens
qui sont élus sur un taux d'abstention
historique continue en fait à dire qu'il
ya un problème avec la façon dont on
fait les élections en france est
d'autant plus en cas de crise decaux
vide
donc il serait peut-être temps de
changer tout ça mexique ou la non non ça
coûte de temps en temps je fais des
alliances avec la droite pour les
municipales et le discours présidentiel
lui se veut écolo on l'a vu avec la
convention citoyenne
oui mais une fois encore qui fait du
théâtre un jeu je ne crois pas que le
mâcon pour une seconde
il raconte il essaye de sauver son parti
qu'il a créé et qui porte les initiales
qui est en train de simplement dissoudre
entre les la façon dont la majorité et
s'organisent à l'assemblée nationale
avec des fausses oppositions entre cette
façon de ne pas avoir de grandes villes
c'est une énorme claque idc fait de
sauver lyon de gagner paris rappelez
vous quand même d'un jardin grisolles
enfin campagne à l'époque où il était
encore candidat
l'ambition était énorme de venir il
fallait vraiment un changement à paris
ça a fait pschitt totalement avec annie
la ministre de la santé parachute est là
pour sauver une campagne en différentes
ça n'a pas aidé du tout il n'y a pas un
moment où ça marche en fait en marche
donc ils vont peut-être se rencontrent à
abandonner les électeurs occident
peut-être s'en rendre compte
mais l'attrait comment savoir et puis
les écolos c'est facile d'avoir un
discours écolo parce que tout le monde
est d'accord on n'est pas contre un
sommet la planète c'est vers discours
fascine parce que tout le monde est
d'accord
après les actes l'effet politique qui
irait dans le sens très écolo voilà rien
à voir avec ce que fait la france mais à
l'opposé donc tout ça est un jeu pour
essayer de polir une image et matrox et
les 90% de communication et 10 % de
mauvaises politiques et bien comment
savoir et dans les urnes et le rif qui
est bien c'est de donner toutes ses
chances à marine le pen qui est nous
présente la mieux placée quoi qu'on en
pense aujourd'hui parce que elle gagne
perpignan puisque elle est vue comme
étant le potentiel malgré les affaires
comme me le rappelait tout à l'heure
alors philippe pascot jean luc mélenchon
s'est exprimé il y à quelques minutes et
lui il parle d'un moment dangereux après
les résultats de ce scrutin est ce que
vous partagez cette complètement c'est
un moment dangereux parce que
malheureusement comme le disait alexis
j'ai bien peur que les gens qui nous
gouvernent aujourd'hui les élus qui nous
représente ne comprennent pas dans quel
marasme ils sont est de plus en plus le
peuple risque de ne plus en avoir
dirt 2 plus rester calme et on se dirige
vers des choses assez grave aussi bien
vers les extrêmes que vers la descente
dans la rue vers l'explosion populaire
on n'arrête pas de crier de hurler
il faut changer de système et si jean
lannes n'écoute pas s'en gausse dans
leur bienséance s'engonce dans le fait
que s'ils font des choses pour le peuple
qui à la limite n'est pas assez
intelligent pour comprendre ce qu'ils
veulent pour nous vous vous rendez
compte en deux ans un petit bout de deux
ans on casse le code du travail on casse
la sécurité sociale on veut casser des
retraites au casque les élections
démocratiques et on continue à dire je
suis un petit peu préoccupé mais ces
gens là
sont fous ils se rendent pas compte que
le peuple il ya 47 millions d'électeurs
ils sont ils vont avoir lu à peine 4
millions de personnes qui ont été qui
les élisent ils se rendent pas compte
qu'ils sont plus rien bizarre il nous
est clairement dit ça va se savoir
je le répète et je le dis ces gens là
aujourd'hui sont élus mais ne sont plus
représentatifs de la population
et quand vous êtes plus représentatif de
la population la population commence à
se lever et à se dire et à dire stop
stop arrêtez arrêtez de nous étouffer
arrêter de nous et nous martyriser
arrêté du nous empêcher de nous exprimer
parce que ils vont pas avoir d'autres
solutions pépère bacrot ne va pas avoir
d'autre solution que de resserrer la vis
resserrer la vis sur plein de choses
vous allez voir dans l'es8 dans les mois
qui suivent de moins en moins on pourra
parler de moi sur moi pour un tir parce
qu'ils ont pas d'une autre champ il
représente plus rien alexis poulain on
va parler de cette forte abstention qui
est historique on peut le dire est ce
que les pour vous les les français ont
eu peur
en tout cas si c'est le cas ça
contrastent avec les images que l'on
voit que ce soit des qg où des
personnalités qui sont allés voter
aujourd'hui où le port du masque
finalement est quelque peu oubliée non
l'éléphante fait alors certains sans
doute routeur compte tenu de la façon
dont avait été gérée le premier tour
avec les morts qui ont suivi avec les
risques de contamination mais je crois
que la majeure partie des gens ne se
sont pas déplacés parce qu'ils s'en
foutent
mais ce que j'aime aller le fassions
tout simplement parce que pour eux voté
ne signifie plus rien parce que voter
pour une personne qui est là simplement
pour sa carrière simplement pour faire
des cadeaux à ses amis ni simplement
parce que derrière il ya une politique
qui n'est pas une politique du bien
commun une politique des lobbys qu'ils
soient locaux ou qu'ils soient
internationaux sa défaite tout le monde
et quand la volonté
de faire autrement d'essayer d'arriver à
mobiliser justement pour noter enfin
pour ça ferait du bien à beaucoup de
gens de voter enfin tôt mais je crois
pas que c'est la volonté de aujourd'hui
les tenants du système qui aurait peur
en fait si les taux de participation à
thématique ça change vraiment la donne
or un taux de participation faible c'est
l'assurance en fait d'avoir les
militants qu'ils s'engagent d'avoir les
femmes qui s'engagent d'avoir finalement
très peu de gens qui vont voter et de
dire derrière j'ai été élu donc taisez
vous c'est moi qui n'étais lui or qu'est
la vienne légitimité des élections à
plus de 60% d'abstention elle est très
faible
elle est extrêmement faible sans compter
qu on ne calcule pas des bulletins
blancs sans compter c'est vraiment ça le
problème aujourd'hui c'est la question
en fait de la représentativité que ce
soit à l'assemblée nationale que ce soit
dans les mairies que ce soit à la tête
de l'état qui sont ces gens qui nous
gouvernent et pour qui gouverne at il
clairement pas pour le peuple et non pas
par le peuple et c'est bien là son
problème le peuple bien sûr c'est un
terme facile parce qu'il est introuvable
il existe des peuples mais quand même il
ya bien quelque chose qui fait que l'on
se sente français
il ya bien quelque chose qui fait qu'on
a aussi le sentiment de l'intérêt commun
de l'intérêt général et qu'à un moment
on voit bien que trop de lobby pour les
lois et pas assez de citoyens en fait
or malheureusement et là il faut le
rappeler c'est le droit le vraiment le
droit le plus important de tous les
citoyens c'est le droit de vote
n'allez pas croire qu'on n'entend pas
les choses ne changeront pas parce que
ce soit la droite la gauche les rêves ou
un autre tout ça sera toujours pareil
c'est faux ce droit de vote
il faut simplement redonner de son
importance et dire aux citoyens combien
il est important parce que cette voie là
elle compte et c'est celle là qui sait
la république parce que derrière vous
inquiétez pas que les élus vont vous
faire la liste de vos devoirs il est
dehors il y en a beaucoup et
malheureusement des droits quand vous
êtes citoyen vous ne rêvez pas tant que
ça est celui qui compte le plus et bien
c'est celui d'élire vous représentant
alors aller voter il va falloir dès à
présent aussi reprendre en main la chose
publique
comprendre que la politique n'est plus
une affaire de sa chambre de l'élite ou
de lentilles s'auto congratule
laisse le choix dit mais la sphère de
tous et que c'est maintenant et au jeu
que les français doivent reprendre en
main leur pays parce que personne va le
faire à leur place
donc malheureusement c'est pas parce que
le président va dire préoccupé qu'il va
perdre les politiques qui vont conduire
les gens à devenir des citoyens actifs à
devenir des gens qui vont aller voter
il ya bien sûr le contexte du coc vide
mais je crois que c'est pas ça le plus
important c'est de voir cette chute
calamiteuse des taux de participation
depuis des années et il n'y avait pas de
crise sanitaire et jeux de voir cette
crise économique qui nous arrive dans la
figure en septembre et ses devoirs
l'apathie générale des populations alors
beaucoup évidemment sont engagés de
manière associative de manière militante
et autres mais à un moment on ne peut
pas continuer de gérer un pays comme ça
à la petite semaine sur un quatre
planches avec un ride roulent derrière
sur un théâtre en fait un théâtre
d'ombrés il va falloir reprendre en main
la démocratie et reprendre en main les
outils de la république française merci
beaucoup alexis poulain d'avoir
participé à cette édition spéciale sur
rt france il est un petit peu plus de
21h heure de paris je vous remercie
également philippe pascot d'avoir
répondu à nos questions sur notre
antenne on va faire un point maintenant
sur sur les chiffres qui se précise ce
soir olivier effectivement thomas bonnet
les chiffres des grandes villes donc on
les connaît notamment à paris ville très
scrutées 1 ce soir lors de ce que vous
avez tous les yeux rivés sur les
résultats à paris et selon les premières
estimations anne hidalgo remporterait
50,2 % des voix loin devant rachida dati
32% selon les estimations et agnès buzyn
complète le podium avec 16% des
suffrages
autre estimation dans une autre grande
ville c'est à lyon je vous en parlais
tout à l'heure
cela semble se confirmer le candidat
écologiste
doucet serait loi si loin devant le
candidat
cucherat donc à lyon et puis on attend
les estimations à bordeaux mais là
encore la tendance est à une forte
percée du candidat écologique
merci beaucoup thomas pour toutes ces
précisions avant de rejoindre nos
invités
patrick mennucci arnaud benedetti donc
on rappelle ces chiffres ce soir sur
paris est la ville tant convoité par la
république en marche paris et lyon qui a
priori ne ne tombe pas dans l'escarcelle
de la république en marche puisque anne
hidalgo remporterait la capitale avec un
peu plus de 50,2 pour cent des voix
devant rachida dati à 32% et agnès buzyn
1 16% olivier direction à présent nos
invités patrick mennucci conseiller
municipal de marseille et ancien
candidat socialiste à la mairie de
marseille ancien député également et
arnaud benedetti rédacteur en chef de la
revue politique et parlementaire il est
également professeur associé à
l'université paris sorbonne mon soir
messieurs merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france patrick mennucci un
commentaire sur paris peut-être non je
je je je n'attendais pas moi mais c'est
la marque d'une municipalité qui a bien
fait son travail qui a intégré la
question avec écologique et dieu sait si
anne hidalgo a été attaqué sur cet
aspect des choses
voilà je crois que c'est tout à fait
satisfaisant nous nous y attendions et
ça fait partie des grandes victoires le
parti socialiste et la gauche ce soir
beaucoup de victoires montpellier est en
train de tomber et je n'ai lu michaël
delafosse d'être le maire voilà il y a
beaucoup de villes moyennes aussi je
crois que la gauche peut être satisfaite
ce soir
benedetti rédacteur en chef de la rue
politique et parlementaire est
actuellement et takaki également par an
avec nous ce soir alors on a vu un la
victoire d'anne hidalgo finalement assez
peu audible le parti socialiste au
niveau national est-ce qu'il peut se
refaire une santé après ces municipales
schickelé l'un des principaux
enseignements si on peut commencer à
tirer des enseignements de ce scrutin
c'est la tectonique des plaques qui est
en train de bouger à gauche entre
finalement l'offre sociale démocrate et
neauphle écologique jusqu'à présent à
gauche
offre sociale démocrate qui était
incarnée par le parti socialiste et elle
offre leader à gauche c'est l'histoire
politique de la gauche depuis maintenant
de nombreuses décennies là on est en
train d'assister vraisemblablement à une
forme de petite révolution culturelle où
l'enjeu environnemental devient dans
l'agenda politique de la gauche l'enjeu
prioritaire
et bien évidemment il est à quoi incarné
par l'offre politique qui historiquement
véhicules enfin en tout cas portent cet
enjeu donc l'une des peut-être dans
propriété manifeste de ce second tour
des élections municipales qui est
d'ailleurs de confirmer
in fine et le premier tour c'est ce qui
est en train de se passer à gauche dans
le rapport de forces entre les
différentes composantes politiques de la
gauche mais je crois quand même que la
presta le sont au delà des résultats
qu'il faut retenir ce soir deux secondes
de ce second tour
c'est la confirmation d'une
participation qui est exceptionnellement
faible historiquement faible au regard
non seulement de l'histoire des scrutins
municipaux depuis maintenant près de de
plus de 60 ans mais également d'autres
scrutins
on est aujourd'hui dans un nettoyage qui
est très faible alors il va falloir
expliquer mes paramètres qui sont à
l'origine aujourd'hui de cette faible
mobilisation
la crise sanitaire vraisemblablement
c'est un paramètre qu'il est important
on l'avait déjà vu lors du premier tour
on le voit alors de ce seulement tour
également mais il ya certainement
d'autres raisons qui peuvent expliquer
aux 6,7
cette faible mobilisation du corps
électoral pour une élection il faut le
rappeler l'élection municipale qui était
une élection traditionnellement
plébiscité par le concitoyen même si ces
dernières années les scrutins municipaux
aussi avait été frappé par une
participation moindre que par le passé
la multiplicité des listes peut être un
début d'explication aussi à ce
désengagement des des électeurs
alors il ya aussi peut-être le fait que
le champ politique national
aujourd'hui est un champ politique qui
est quand même profondément
alors on viard chiper lisez moi je
dirais plutôt balkaniser c'est à dire où
finalement les offres politiques
nationales paraissent extrêmement
complexes voire parfois confuse dans
leur positionnement et on l'a vu encore
une fois à lors de ce second tour des
élections municipales où on a vu des
jeux d'alliances sur le plan local qui
parfois pouvait être surprenant les
républicains la droite qui soutient
martine martine aubry par exemple à
lille donc vous voyez que là il y avait
120 il dit dans une scène politique qui
a du mal à ceux à se re stabiliser alors
peut-être que ça explique aussi cette
démobilisation
ce sera en tout cas un des facteurs
qu'il faudra lever sans laurent analysé
merci arnaud benedetti vous restez avec
nous a tout de suite prendre la
direction de la rue vaugirard au qg des
républicains retrouvez notre reporter à
mona amoudé l'or alors mona rachida dati
a vraisemblablement perdu à paris ce
soir
alors on se trouve devant le qg de
rachida dati boulevard sébastopol et
l'ambiance ici bien elle est très calme
il faut le dire puisque rachida dati est
arrivé en seconde position avec 32% des
voix selon harris interactive très loin
derrière anne hidalgo avec 50,2 pour
cent et des fêtes et rasant pour agnès
buzyn avec 16% attention elle ces
chiffres sont susceptibles de changer
concernant le taux de participation a
paris il est de 23,89 % contre 38 60 %
en 2014 une très forte baisse donc une
grosse déception pour la droite ici à
paris rachida dati ne s'est pas encore
exprimée en tout cas elle aura
l'occasion ici de sortir par cette
entrée qu'on peut voir juste derrière
moi on a pu voir son service de sécurité
la candidate rachida dati qui
représentait un petit peu l espoir
politique des républicains n'a
vraisemblablement pas su convaincre l
est parisien elle estimé pourtant être
la mieux placée est la plus déterminée à
gagner la mairie de paris s et
municipales elle était aussi l'occasion
pour les républicains de rebondir sur la
scène politique notamment après l'échec
des européennes ou encore les élections
présidentielles en ce qui concerne la
province le premier tour a été assez
gratifiant pour à l'est républicain
puisque plusieurs villes ont été à
gagner d'avant s'il a fallu parfois
faire des alliances avec elle la
république en marche au premier tour le
parti politique avait revendiqué 30% à
des villes de plus de 9000 habitants et
56% avec ses alliés les maires sortants
comme françois baroin a par exemple pour
la ville de troyes ou encore arnaud
robinet à reims où natacha bouchart à
calais avait été réélu sans difficulté
selon christian jacob l'ambition était
de continuer sur cette voie en tout cas
à paris ce n'est pas le cas il y a cette
défaite de rachida dati
les 11e et les enjeux étaient néanmoins
important pour aller république à paris
christian jacob lui prendra la parole
aux alentours de 21h30 22h et on
écoutera cela bien sûr avec nous merci
mona amoud et l'or en direct du qg de 1
rachida dati on va écouter edouard
philippe à présent qui lui a à gagner
dans son ancienne mairie du havre le
premier ministre qui était qui se
présentait sans étiquette à la mairie
d'hyères qui n'avaient pas forcément
beaucoup de voix d'avancé en tout cas
pas mais en tout cas sûre pour ce
scrutin il a donc remporté la mairie
avec 58 points 83 % des voix face au
député pcf jean-paul lecoq selon les
premières estimations
on écoute le premier ministre on va
saluer l'engagement de tous ceux qui ont
été candidats wavre
ou ailleurs et je voudrais d'ailleurs
félicité très sincèrement mon adversaire
jean paul lecoq
je n'ai pas évidemment d'accord avec ses
convictions mais je les respecte comme
je le respecte lui et je voudrais saluer
tous ceux qui en france se sont engagés
quels que soient leurs idées pour
essayer de les faire valoir
démocratiquement et permettez moi
d'insister sur ce démocratiquement
encore une fois en france les choix sont
faits par ceux qui se déplacent pour
aller voter et ceux qui sont élus
doivent ensuite avoir la charge de
conduire les affaires publiques
alors patrick mennucci on vient donc
d'entendre le premier ministre edouard
philippe qui a remporté donc l'élection
de mer au havre agnès buzyn également à
paris mais cette fois n'a pas remporté
agnès buzyn effectivement à paris votre
réaction patrick mennucci sûr c'est un
ministère d'état de ses ministres à ce
scrutin des municipales ajouté je crois
que ce qui me paraît important c'est
dans une élection il vraiment ce qu'on
regarde ville par ville mais il me
semble que ce soir c'est pas la victoire
d'edouard philippe au havre qui peut
cacher la débandade de la république en
marche dans cette élection et je note
d'ailleurs que les mères qui ont vu dans
le passé être socialiste et qui ont
rejoint la république en marche sont
battus ce soir je pense à lorient et je
pense surtout à montpellier où michael
delafosse demain c'est confirmé a fait
basculer la ville qui revient la ville
de georges frêche qui revient au parti
socialiste dont kylie a aujourd'hui plus
de 60 villes nouvelles qui vont être
dirigée par un maire socialiste alors je
sais qu'on va dire que il y a la
victoire des bords philippe mais en
aucun cas elle ne peut masquer les
analyses qui seront faites sur le fait
que le parti guéiste retrouve beaucoup
de communes et gagne et regagne des
communes qu'il avait perdue par exemple
à périgueux ou à tyrosse des villes
moyennes grandes sur tout le territoire
c'est je crois très important pour la
gauche aujourd'hui mennucci donc vous
dit clairement que cette élection est un
vote sanction pour la république en
marche et un petit peu de vigueur
retrouvée pour le parti socialiste qui
en manquait grandement je ne vais pas
dire que c'est
c'était une sanction pour la république
en moi je pense que ce serait pas la
vérité la république est en marche à
tous et je dirais pour ne pas être au
fond prises au sérieux par les électeurs
et présente les candidats qu'ils ont
présentés n'étaient pas prêts ils ont
polémiqué entre parfois il ya eu des
listes dissidentes
non je crois que il faut distinguer les
choses il y a dans la nièvre la crise
sanitaire
la crise sanitaire a eu un impact selon
vous la gestion des pages je ne sais pas
il faudra avoir le résultat de toulouse
peut-être mais regardez à bourges où le
maire a fait des distributions de masque
pendant trois mois ils viennent d'être
battus par l'ancien député socialiste et
yann galut donc moi ce qui me semble
surtout c'est que le parti socialiste
est un parti de formation un parti qui
construit localement territorialement de
bonne politique et cesser bonne
politique
ce soir qui sont qui ont été mises en
avant par les électeurs quand les
électeurs nous ont donné la majorité
dans autant de villes et je crois pas
qu'il faille en tirer des conséquences
de sanctions il faut simplement
remarquer que la république est en
marche qui n'est pas un parti politique
il y a une personnalité
emmanuel macron qui effectivement une
personnalité qui compte beaucoup au
premier rang dans ce pays mais il n'a
pas derrière lui une organisation qui
traditionnellement sont les
organisations des partis et un jour ça
lui posera un problème
or nos benedetti quelles perspectives
aujourd'hui selon vous répond la
république en marche après les résultats
de ce soir
oui alors je rejoue à bâtir l uci sur
finalement l'échec de la
professionnalisation du parti politique
de l'entreprise politique de la répu
ik marche qui aujourd'hui à une force et
une faiblesse sa force c'est quand même
emmanuel macron et une base sociologique
qui sur le plan électoral
on l'avait vu lors du dernier scrutin
européen reste malgré tout si ce n'est
forte mais en tout cas solide mais qui
n'a pas su se transformer en parti
politique susceptible de s'implanter
territorialement
c'est quand même je pense là aussi assez
rare de voir un parti présidentiel aussi
faible localement ça c'est un hiatus qui
aujourd'hui pose une difficulté pour la
majorité
alors les perspectives aujourd'hui des
perspectives pour emmanuel macron c'est
bien évidemment une élection façon cette
élection municipale on va compris qu'il
avait d'une certaine manière enjambées
mais il avait enjambé bien avant la
crise sanitaire
parce que tout avait été fait dans la
stratégie de la république en marche
depuis
finalement plusieurs mois pour rendre
une certaine manière ou en tout cas
essayer de rendre illisible ces
résultats afin que on n'en tire pas
forcément des enseignements nationaux
sur la gestion du pays par là l'exécutif
et ça et sa majorité
aujourd'hui les madiama quand il est
confronté à un défi qui est le défi de
répondre à une crise sociale et une
crise économique qui est directement qui
existait déjà avant la crise sanitaire
mais qui est bien évidemment aujourd'hui
amplifiée à la puissance mille par la
crise sanitaire
on avait vu déjà un emmanuel macron
après la crise des gilet jaune nous
composer un acte 2 mais cet acte ii il
était essentiellement tournée vers un
changement de méthode c'est à dire il
voulait finalement que ce quinquennat
soit d'une certaine manière plus
participatif qu'on puisse plus court
construit en tout cas dans son discours
et dans sa sémantique les politiques le
public qu'il proposerait aux français de
l'eau d'ailleurs la convention citoyenne
sur le climat qui était une
une des réponses à la crise désillusion
d'apporter par emmanuel macron mai
une fine et on a vu notamment lors de la
réforme des retraites que ce ce logiciel
qu'ils essayaient de mettre en place ne
fonctionnait pas tout simplement parce
que c'était logiciels qu'ils
n'appliqueraient pas véritablement dans
sa façon de construire cette politique
publique aujourd'hui il est finalement
confronté autre chose qu'un problème de
méthode il est confronté à un problème
de fond c'est à dire que est ce que il
est en mesure de transformer le logiciel
politique qui a été le sien qui a été
celui à l'origine de son élection
on a vu depuis finalement trois mois 1
emmanuel macron qui a essayé
d'introduire dans son discours politique
des mots et des concepts qui jusqu'à
présent il était de manière périphérique
voir qu'il était complètement absente
c'est le mot de souveraineté il parle de
souveraineté européenne c'est le mot de
relocalisation c'est le mot d'économie
verte il en a parlé tout récemment il ya
quinze jours lors de son adresse aux
français donc
va-t-il entamé un tournant politique qui
d'une certaine manière et constitue une
nouvelle étape dans le monde ah ça c'est
la première question quelle ligne
politique la deuxième question c'est
ensuite la question que tout le monde va
se poser dès ce soir et dès demain matin
avec quelle femme et qu'elle nomme le
leu leu leu quand vous voulez changer de
ligne politique
il y a une façon disons absolument va
dire essentiel et opératoire pour
changer de ligne politique c'est de
changer l'homme qui est en charge de
mettre en musique c'est une politique
énorme qui est en charge de mettre en
musique cette ligne politique dans le
système de la vème république c'est le
premier ministre donc il est clair que
si il maintient edouard philippe
on verra que nous resterons nous restons
dans une forme de continuité même si on
peut imaginer qu'il y aura des
ajustements
s'il change de premier ministre alors là
peut-être ça serait un signal en tout
cas de changement de politique
nous allons le voir dans son pré
rapidement mais chargés de premier
ministre dans la conjoncture que nous
traversons c'est difficile voire
d'europe
parce que le premier ministre est
aujourd'hui populaire bon on a vu par le
passé des présidents de la république se
séparer de cynisme populaire ça a été le
cas de du général de gaulle et plus près
nous françois mitterrand avec michel
rocard mais enfin c'est quand même
toujours difficile
et ensuite il faut trouver une ressource
qui soit capable d'incarner
éventuellement une nouvelle vie
politique ça c'est un autre sujet et on
voit que du côté de la république en
marche
aujourd'hui il y a manifestement une
pénurie aussi de personnalités
susceptibles d'être une alternative
par exemple aujourd'hui à bord suis dit
on va en parler de ce remaniement au
cours de cette soirée la porte-parole du
gouvernement si bête ndiaye s'est dit
ldc ce soir à la suite de ces premiers
résultats
je vous laisse découvrir ça sa
déclaration à l'écran ce soir nous
éprouvons une déception parce qu'il y à
des endroits vous avez cité lyon à
l'instant où notre propre division
interne nous a conduit à des scores
extrêmement décevant donc cet aveu
d'échec de la part de la porte-parole du
gouvernement et autres déclarations ce
soir celle de jean-luc mélenchon
magali il s'agit d'un moment dangereux
at il dit pour les français le leader de
la france insoumise elle s'est exprimée
sur sa chaîne youtube regarder
clairement la marche du peuple français
est en grève civique
c'est une forme d'insurrection froide
contre toutes les institutions du pays
au moment où l'état voit son autorité
s'effondrait dans les comportements de
la police être mis en cause par ceux de
la justice
c'est donc un moment compliqué dangereux
de la vie de la nation qui se présentent
devant nous et on va faire un nouveau
point avec vous thomas bonnin concernant
les derniers chiffres notamment ceux
concernant europe ecologie les verts
mais c'est une des grandes tendances de
cette soirée du second tour des
municipales la percée des écologistes
dans plusieurs villes d'ailleurs yannick
jadot salut je cite la victoire d'une
espérance autour d'un beau projet
écologiste dans plusieurs villes et ça
se concrétise notamment dans la ville de
lyon où grégory doucet serait en tête
devant yann cucherat c'était loin d'être
acquis après les résultats du premier
tour c'est la tendance qui se dessine
avec ses premières estimations
autre surprise c'est dans la ville de
bordeaux où là encore le candidat
écologiste pierre hurmic serait en tête
devant nicolas florian nicolas florian
qui est le successeur d'alain juppé et
qui avait pu compter sur le ralliement
du candidat de la république en marche
thomas cazenave et bien cela n'a
vraisemblablement pas suffi puisque je
vous le répète c'est donc le candidat
pierre hurmic qui serait en tête à
bordeaux selon les premières estimations
font revenir aussi sur la situation à
lille parce que depuis tout à l'heure
nous affirmons tout quand on vous montre
que la tendance est à la défaite de
martine aubry s'assemblent en est en
réalité beaucoup plus serré que ce qu'il
était au départ puisque selon son
entourage martine aubry revendique une
courte victoire s'est pas encore acquis
les estimations ne permettent pas à
l'heure actuelle date
donner des résultats précis mais là
encore c'est un candidat d'europe
écologie les verts en l'occurrence
stéphane baly qui est au coude à coude
avec la maire sortante martine aubry qui
on le rappelle brigue un quatrième
mandat dans la ville de lille avait
refusé de faire alliance avec la liste
des écologistes est ce qui nous amène
donc à cette situation particulièrement
compliqué pour martine aubry ce soir a
dit c'est donc à lille
patrick mennucci on l'a vu dans l'ailé
les écolos tirent leur épingle du jeu en
tout cas de ces municipales déjà au
premier tour le second semble confirmer
cette tendance
l'alliance qui n'a pas été fait avec
martine aubry c'est une première je
crois depuis 1977 et les écolos qui qui
qui qui font les qui sont faisant de
roissy je puis m'exprimer ainsi
aujourd'hui pour les socialistes
écoutez la reine la reine martin est
resté sur son trône
et pendant que nous parlions il ya eu ce
changement
et moi je veux le dire je suis très
heureux pour elle très heureux pour ce
qu'elle a fait elle a été assez mal
traités parce que les parfois les les
écologistes exagère un peu et elle avait
mené une politique très écologiste à
lille et on a essayé de la faire passer
pour ce que n'était pas en tout cas elle
a remis les pendules à l'heure en
quelques minutes et je trouve que c'est
une très bonne chose ne semble pas nous
parlons il y a des dizaines de villes
qui sont en train de basculer marseille
va certainement de bascule et je peux
vous annoncer que le front national est
battu dans son secteur
que madame galy nationale le
rassemblement national pendant l'e3 est
battu dans ce secteur madame galy et
telus dans le sien très largement et je
crois pouvoir dire que martine vassal et
battu dans ce secteur ne sais pas pour
les autres mais en tout cas
manifestement martine vassal ne sera pas
maire de marseille donc il y a la une
une situation qui est
qui est tout à fait intéressante on a
beau dire ce sont des municipales il n'y
a pas eu beaucoup de votants mais en
cinq ans même tout à l'heure vous m'avez
posé la question ça c'était une sanction
pour le gouvernement
je ne sais pas si c'est une samedi en
bourgogne en tout cas ce n'est pas une
bonne chose mais ce que je constate
aussi c'est que les républicains qui ont
une position très ambiguë à l'égard de
la république en mars payent les pots
cassés parce que à bordeaux il y avait
un accord entre la république en marché
et les républicains
qu en est-il de strasbourg on me dit que
les choses sont extrêmement tendues
voilà je crois qu'il y à là ce soir le
retour quand même de la gauche dans le
pays
ça se voyait dans le climat qu'on
pouvait avoir mais on voit que les
électeurs ont quand même traduit cela en
faisant confiance à des équipes parfois
dirigé par des écologistes très souvent
dirigées par des socialistes
effectivement il est clair qu'il y a une
importance pour nous aujourd'hui à nous
rassembler le parti socialiste il est
prêt mais nous avons aussi notre
spécificité notre spécificité c'est
notre nature sociale et il faudra
trouver la formule pour aller ensemble
aux prochaines élections anne était en
partie aux formes de ces deux
orientations qui doivent maintenant se
confondent itc américaine
quand je dois finir ça veut dire
également avec la france en sourit on le
sait un la gauche n'était pas parti avec
monsieur mélenchon problème est toujours
le même
c'est pas le parti socialiste qui veut
pas s'unir avec lui c'est lui qui a une
détestation expliquez moi pourquoi jean
luc mélenchon mais pas présents dans ces
élections municipales pourquoi il n'y a
pas de liste de la france est soumise
pourquoi les élus de la française louise
qui seront élus se soient sont cachés
dans des listes citoyenne ou je ne sais
quoi
ce n'est pas c'est une boucle d'une
façon étonnante de faire les choses
maintenant si jean luc mélenchon voulait
soutenir un candidat et que nous ayons
le même candidat lui les verts et le
parti socialiste je pense qu'on
terminerait avec l'épisode macron arnaud
belletti attendions la crise sanitaire
on a beaucoup entendu cette expression
le monde d'après est ce que au fond
europe et écologie les verts pourraient
finalement incarner ce fameux monde
d'après côté c'est très difficile d'y
répondre moi ce que je crois quand même
deux choses par rapport à ce que vient
de dire patrick dauchy en effet il a
raison aujourd'hui
disons la gauche le pôle de la gauche ce
que l'on appelait du temps de lionel
jospin la gauche plurielle mais la
gauche plurielle était à l'époque avec
avarie centre était plutôt du côté du ps
en tout cas peut se satisfaire de
résultats qui sont même à peu près
inespéré au regard de l'état de la
gauche il y a il y a un an mais il faut
quand même module et il faut moduler
parce que ce qui est quand même frappant
encore une fois est qu'on le veuille ou
non c'est le taux d'abstention qui
demeure extrêmement important et qui
demeure massif
donc il y à là quand même une leçon
qu'il faut retenir c'est que cette
élection municipale a été une élection
municipale qui s'est traduite par un
retrait civique retrait citoyens qui
constitue une véritable interrogation
pour d'ailleurs l'ensemble du monde
politique tout en bords politiques
confondus
je crois que il ne faut pas totalement
vers s'économiser une réflexion sur ce
sur ce sujet le deuxième point et qui à
mon sens est une question d'ordre quasi
sociologique c'est que c'est l'échec là
pour le coup de la république en marche
c'est que la république est en marche
avec honte avait construit sa sa base
électorale sur les grandes métropoles
qui avait d'ailleurs largement voté pour
emmanuel macron lors de la dernière
élection présidentielle là ce qui est en
train de se passer avec les élections
municipales c'est que ces grandes
métropoles sont en train aujourd'hui 2
soit confirmée des élus de gauche soit
porté à la tête de ces municipalités des
élus de gauche donc ce qui est
finalement doit être constitutive doit
être considérée comme un véritable échec
pour le parti majoritaire c'est que il
n'a pas réussi à mobiliser sa base
électorale sa sociologie électorale
danser dans ses fiefs en tout cas tel
que les avait dessiné l'élection
présidentielle et même l'élection
européenne
de ce point de vue là le résultat de
paris constitue une très mauvaise
nouvelle pour la république en marche on
voit que non seulement madame du vin est
très loin mais que même son score
diminuer par rapport au premier tour
donc on a aujourd'hui un parti
majoritaire qui veut incarner le monde
d'après mais qui ne retrouve pas sa
sociologie électorale dans ses fiefs et
qui n'arrivent pas à conquérir une autre
sociologie électorale dans les zones
périphériques ou là en effet il y à
d'autres forces politiques qui le
concurrence fortement
donc la question du monde après pour
l'instant qui à mes yeux restent plutôt
un slogan de marketing plutôt qu'une
réalité politique je ne suis pas sûr
qu'il y ait dans l'esprit de nos
compatriotes une force politique qui
soit en mesure de l'incarner encore une
fois ce qui est quand même très frappant
dans les résultats de ce soir c'est
l'atomisation d'une certaine manière du
champ politique qui continue à se
poursuivre élection après élection est
donc ces élections municipales au niveau
local constitue une nouvelle
illustration
merci merci beaucoup a renouvellé betty
patrick mennucci vous êtes d'accord avec
ça on assiste à une atomisation delà de
la politique ce soir les aider à les
cartes sont rebattues selon vous je
crois pas je ne sais pas pourquoi
atomisation dans un deuxième tour de
toute façon on a toujours de liste c'est
vrai si c'est ce que veut dire monsieur
benedetti il y avait beaucoup de
triangulaire et de cadres angulaire dans
cette élection
mais c'est l'émergence de la république
est en marche et aussi la poursuite de 2
du front national mais je crois qu'il
faut essayer d'être simple on va le 15
mars il y avait des résultats qui
étaient absolument exceptionnel pour la
gauche dans tout le pays
malheureusement la situation sanitaire
n'a pas permis aux français d'en prendre
conscience et aux commentateurs de de
faire les commentaires c'est hélas ce
soir on parle de 13% des municipalités 1
et non pas de la france et cela et vous
avez tout à fait raison de le souligner
est responsable et municipalités mais
quand même 40 % des habitants des
français là ce soir on a quand même
quelque chose de care il y a
la perte de 2 2 lyon il y à la perte de
bordeaux il y à la perte de nancy pour
la droite qui sont quand même des villes
qui fait briller les reins mais pour la
droite qui sont game des villes qui
étaient des fiefs bouckaert idéologique
de cette ligne là il y a des dizaines de
communes de plus de 10 mille habitants
où la gauche et singulièrement le parti
socialiste parce qu'elle donc fera les
comptes
on s'apercevra que le parti socialiste
droit certainement dix fois ce buzz fois
plus de mer que les écologistes ou que
les communistes que le parti socialiste
est en situation de moi ce que je crois
c'est que c'est un signe bien sûr pour
le pays
mais c'est surtout un signe pour les
socialistes qui doute ceux qui pensent
que leur parti est fichue excusez moi du
terme
ceux qui pensent que leur parti 9
plus rien et bien ce soir les électeurs
dans les territoires on dit aux élus
socialistes
vous avez fait un bon travail et vous
qui proposait un programme
je vous soutiennent et vous êtes vous
êtes mont mera bien cela devrait être
quelque chose de fondamental dans
l'esprit des dirigeants socialistes pour
se reconstruire en passant bien sûr des
accords avec europe ecologie les verts
et avec les autres forces de gauche
mais le parti socialiste doit reprendre
de la fierté ce soir c'est ça que je
crois qu'il y ait pour moi ce qui est le
plus important de ce qui se passe dans
cette élection
vous restez avec nous patrick mennucci
ainsi qu'arnaud bbb clients on va faire
un point maintenant sur l'abstention qui
est historique pour ce scrutin local
effectivement thomas bonnin très très
fort taux d'abstention ce soir
historique le disait magali près de 60%
qu'est ce qu'on peut en retenir à cette
heure-là effectivement le taux
d'abstention serait autour de 60% c'est
évidemment un record il faut bien
préciser qu'au premier tour de ces
élections municipales la participation
s'élevait alors à 45 5 % on serait donc
en recul par rapport à ces chiffres on
imagine évidemment que le premier tour
de ces élections a été fortement
impactée par la crise sanitaire on
rappelle que le premier tour s'est tenu
le 15 mars dernier quelques jours
seulement avant le confinement annoncé
en france la situation sanitaire s'est
quelque peu améliorée avec le
déconfinement et malgré cela la
participation est encore en baisse par
rapport au premier tour ne serait ce que
par rapport au premier tour de cette de
ces élections municipales c'est une
tendance au final un peu plus longues à
plus long terme c'est à dire que depuis
plusieurs années le scrutin municipal ne
réunit plus longtemps que ce qu'il a pu
le faire dans les années 70 ou 80 il
semblerait que cette abstention favorise
certaines certains partis en tout cas
par exemple europe ecologie les verts
semblent résister davantage à cette
faible participation puisqu'on a appris
selon les estimations qui viennent de
nous parvenir qu'à strasbourg
le candidat de la république en marche
serait là aussi devancé par la candidate
écologiste qui est en lice à strasbourg
c'est madame jeanne bars et guillon et
puis à marseille également où michel
rubio là serait largement en tête avec
10 points avant ce sont là encore des
estimations merci beaucoup thomas alors
arnaud benedetti on le disait un l'une
des informations marquantes c'est le
taux d'abstention ce soir le maire salle
toujours été l'élu préféré des français
est-ce que c'est toujours le cas selon
vous est-ce que ce taux d'abstention
aussi fort marc finalement un autre
regard des citoyens français sur le mets
sur les mers
non je crois pas qu'il faille tirer
cette conclusion d'ivoire une défiance
vis-à-vis du maire et du pouvoir
municipal et l'échelon local dans son
ensemble toutes les études qui ont été
réalisées maintenant depuis un certain
nombre d'années deux mois encore
récemment ont démontré que la
personnalité politique qui bénéficié du
plus fort au degré de confiance c'était
le maire donc il n'y a pas de de dison
de défiance dans la personnalité du
maire parce que tout simplement le maire
c'est un élu que l'on créditent d'une
capacité à faire d'une capacité à être
concret et d'une capacité de proximité
d'une capacité à pouvoir répondre sur le
terrain aux problèmes que lui cause de
ses administrés contrairement parfois
justement d'autres catégories d'élus
donc savent pas que c'est pas le c'est
pas le souci principal est s'esquive
récents moment aujourd'hui n'est pas en
cause le temps le scrutin que nous
vivons moi je veux bien me pardonner -
la priorité au direct on va devoir
prendre la direction de perpignan je
vous remercie en tout cas d'avoir
participé à cette édition spéciale sur
rt france merci beaucoup à vous
également patrick mennucci d'avoir fait
vivre cette soirée électorale sur notre
antenne on va prendre tout de suite la
direction de perpignan pour rejoindre
notre reporter nadège abderrazak qui est
accompagné de louis aliot
elle
louis aliot oui le nouvel homme fort de
perpignan louis aliot qui a remporté
cette élection municipale après trois
tentatives
bonsoir merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation sur arte france donc
troisième tentative première victoire
comment vous avez réussi à convaincre
les perpignanais de voter en votre
faveur
goûtez ça fait longtemps que je même
planté et je pense avoir trouvé aussi
une équipe et cette équipe aujourd'hui
elle va être en charge de la mairie et
je pense que perpignan devait tourner
une page c'était un vieux système
politique et je pense que voilà il
fallait du renouveau il fallait des
nouveaux visages
il fallait un nouveau maire et c'était
le moment ou jamais de le faire un front
républicain a été mise en place pour
faire barrage aux au rassemblement
national c'est la stratégie qui est
menée depuis 2002 maintenant à cette
stratégie
clairement il ne fonctionne plus
aujourd'hui mais je pense qu'elle s'est
effondré après à perpignan puisque la
seule contre tous mais il faut vraiment
le dire on a réussi à l'emporter ça
prouve que ce front républicain était
une escroquerie politique qui ne repose
sur rien et que les gens qui appellent
systématiquement à barrer la route à
quelqu'un eh bien les citoyens n'en
veulent plus et la preuve c'est ce soir
et j'espère que ça servira de leçon à
tous les autres marine le pen vous a
félicité ce soir elle vous a félicité
d'avoir réussi à rassembler même la
gauche ici à perpignan ce sont des mots
qui vous touche de la part de la
présidente du rassemblement national
bien sûr elle est à la tête très
certainement aujourd'hui du plus grand
parti de france
même si les municipales ne sont pas de
notre élection on va quand même le dire
mais il y a des départementales
à défendre il ya des régionales voilà la
présidentielle à venir et elle sait
pouvoir compter
j'allais dire sur des cadres fidèle et
je pense que toutes les équipes partout
en france seront désormais j'allais dire
au soutien de toute la politique à mener
tout le renouveau politique à faire en
france aujourd'hui
la dernière question à louis aliot a à
quoi va ressembler le perpignan de louis
aliot accord avec sont interdits en plus
sûres où les jeunes auront enfin un
avenir plus propre aussi et un perpignan
qui aura valeur d'exemple en matière de
qualité de vie
parce qu'on a rien à dire une situation
paradoxale on est une très belle ville
un patrimoine magnifique
on est dans une situation géographique
elle aussi privilégiées et pourtant on
cumule tous les mauvais chiffres
eh bien il faut sortir de cette de cette
chose de là et je pense que mon équipe
et moi même serons à la hauteur de la
situation
commencé le travail dès la semaine
prochaine dès la semaine prochaine on
sera installé à partir de samedi et de
dimanche au travail si beaucoup et louis
louis aliot donc un nouveau maire donc
de la ville de perpignan donc vous
l'avez entendu louis aliot qui est bien
va se mettre au travail assez rapidement
qui a répondu donc qui eux qui avaient
bien célèbre cette victoire à la mairie
de perpignan avec beaucoup beaucoup
d'humilité ce soir merci beaucoup nadège
navez abderrazak en direct de perpignan
il est presque 21h40 édition spéciale
sur rt france on va tout de suite faire
un point avec vous tous gabonais sur les
chiffres qu'il faut retenir à cette
heure avec une poussée des verts ce soir
poussée des verts dans plusieurs villes
de france plusieurs grandes villes de
france honda parle d'abord de lyon où
c'était loin d'être acquis importants et
bien grégory doucet serait en tête selon
les premières estimations une forte
large avance
selon ces mêmes estimations pour le
candidat d'europe écologie les verts qui
devance yann cucherat percée également
des écologistes à bordeaux où c'est pour
l'occurrence pierre hurmic qui serait en
tête devant nicolas florian nicolas
florian qui on le rappelle est le
successeur d'alain juppé à la mairie de
bordeaux au premier tour seule une
petite centaine de voix séparaient les
deux hommes nicolas florian le candidat
les républicains qui avaient pu compter
sur le ralliement du candidat de la
république en marche bien cela n'a
semble-t-il pas suffi puisque selon ses
estimations c'est donc pierre hurmic qui
est en tête coude à coude également à
lille où martine aubry n'est pas encore
assuré d'être réélu à la tête de la
mairie puisque là encore c'est un
candidat d'europe écologie les verts qui
lui dispute la victoire stéphane baly
les le car est très très serré ça va se
jouer à quelques suffrages on attend la
fin définitive
enfin complète du dépouillement dans la
ville de lille résultats également à
strasbourg où c'est là encore la
candidate écologiste et écologistes
jeune marc ses clients qui arrivent en
tête devant le candidat de la république
en marche puis à marseille c'est michel
ruby rôle à la candidate qui a réalisé
une alliance de la gauche qui serait là
aussi en tête avec une large avance
selon les premières estimations points
quand même pour de satisfaction pour la
république en marche c'est à toulouse où
le candidat jean luc moudenc qui est
soutenu à la fois par les républicains
et par la république en marche
résistera est là aussi la à la percée du
candidat d'europe écologie les verts
antoine maurice puisque jean luc moudenc
serait en tête
selon les premières estimations les
verts transforme l'essai donc merci
thomas
merci beaucoup et on attend évidemment
les résultats de la ville de marseille
où là aussi ça pourrait basculer après
le long règne de jean claude gaudin on
va retrouver tout de suite boulevard
sébastopol au qg de campagne de rachida
dati notre reporter mona amoud et laure
mona bonsoir qu'en est il de votre côté
les républicains qui sont assez
silencieux ce soir en étant là le
discours en tout cas de rachida dati qui
a perdu la mairie de paris ce soir
[Musique]
mais c'est le cas de le dire magali très
silencieux très calme en tout cas ici
regardez juste derrière moi il ya une
horde de journalistes qui attendent la
venue de rachida dati qui devrait
arriver d'ici quelques instants on aura
peut-être l'occasion de la voir arriver
juste derrière nous en tout cas on a vu
arriver sa famille très réservé ses
soeurs qui passait ici pour justement
elle à soutenir puisqu'elle n'a pas
encore pris la parole rachida dati qui
est d'ailleurs arrivé en seconde
position loin derrière hidalgo avec 32%
des voix selon harris interactive et
anne hidalgo avec 50,2 % et l écrasante
défaite d'agnès abusant de la république
en marche avec l 16% ces chiffres sont
susceptibles de changer tout au long de
la soirée le taux de participation à
paris à 17 heures était de 23,89 %
contre 38,60 en 2014 une très grosse
baisse et une très grosse déception
aussi pour les républicains qui a tenté
beaucoup de ceux de sète de ce second
tour
grosset déception et surtout pour
rachida dati qui avait déclaré qu'elle
méritait et qu'elle était déterminée à
gagner cette mairie de paris cette
candidate est bien l incarner un petit
peu l'espoir pour les républicains l
espoir pour revenir un petit peu au
devant de la scène politique après
plusieurs défaites notamment aux
européennes ou encore lé présidentielle
ces municipales elle était un rebond
elle peut représenter en tout cas un
rebond politique et il y avait beaucoup
beaucoup d'enjeu pour les républicains
par compte en province le ton est assez
différent en tout cas au premier tour
plusieurs villes avaient été gagnées
d'avancé plusieurs maires avaient été
réélus dès la première fois comme par
exemple dès le premier tour par don
comme françois baroin à 3 ou encore
arnaud robinet
un sou natacha bouchart qui ont été
réélu sans difficulté vous le voyez
encore en arrière mois des journalistes
qui attendent l avenue de rachida dati
christian jacob lui devrait s'exprimer
peut-être d'ici quelques minutes ou aux
alentours de 22h et rachida dati
également qui est attendu de pied ferme
ici à son qg boulevard sébastopol à
paris
merci beaucoup moins à nous pour toutes
ces précisions rachida dati qui on le
précise avait remporté en tout cas la
mairie du 7e arrondissement dès le
premier tour la seule en tout cas avoir
emporté dès le premier tour un
arrondissement à paris
les républicains qui perdent aussi
perpignan perpignan que le maire sortant
jean marc pujol a donc été battu par
louis aliot ce soir c'est une grosse
prise pour le rassemblement national
on va écouter marine le pen qui s'est
exprimée quelques temps un peu après
justement cette victoire à perpignan
écoutez la marion je pense que beaucoup
de gens ont voté pour lui à llo y
compris d'ailleurs des gens qui venaient
de la gauche il avait d'ailleurs sur sa
liste les gens qui venaient de la gauche
il avait également des personnes qui
étend sur d'autres listes avaient appelé
à voter pour lui au second tour mais je
crois que c'est vraiment la victoire du
rassemblement des français autour d'un
projet autour d'une équipe autour d'une
ville qui il faut bien le dire concentre
l'ensemble des échecs de la politique
menée par les dirigeants français depuis
des années
l'insécurité la division le chômage
l'effondrement économique
c'est à tout cela que lui et son équipe
vont devoir répondre maintenant ils le
font j'en suis sûr avec beaucoup de
sérieux beaucoup de pugnacité beaucoup
de compétences et voilà pour la
déclaration de marine le pen après la
victoire de louis aliot on le rappelle
son ancien compagnon qui a donc gagné la
mairie à perpignan et on va rejoindre
tout de suite nos
entre autres invités ce soir et oui il
s'agit de 10 ans n'a pas dit un
porte-parole du parti socialiste
adjointe au maire des mureaux dianaba
diop merci depp
donnez-moi stéphane qui qui qui est avec
une secrétaire général adjoint de droite
libre stéphane tiki merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur arte france
peut-être une première réaction le
concernant le taux d'abstention ce soir
oui je pense que tous les partis
politiques aujourd'hui d'abord se
remettre en question sur l'abstention
qui est quand même assez fort ça montre
que les gens n'ont pas été intéressés
ça montre aussi que le scrutin a été
compliqué ça et consorts s'étaient
d'épidémie du coville
après des mois et des mois donc il
jouera que pour les élections prochaines
nous nous remettons les autres en
question pour redonner envie aux gens et
aux français de reprendre la vie
politique et que pensez vous de la
position les républicains ce soir qui
ont perdu certaines grosses viella
priori pour l'instant on attend encore
les résultats notamment à marseille et
bordeaux qui sont pas encore totalement
définitif en revanche
rappelons quand même que à l'issue du
premier tour les répliques étaient
majoritaires et ce sera encore le cas au
lac à l'issue du second tour avec la
plupart des villes qui ont été gagnés je
pense à des villes comme toulouse je
pense à des villes où françois baron
était là lui daniel fasquelle étaient
réunis au touquet on poitiers on april
oriant lorient qui est une ville qui
était à gauche depuis 1965 a basculé
aussi n'ont qu'à pas mal de vivre qui
ont alors basculé à droite des
républicains ont été prompts forte on
avait une vague bleue effectivement 2014
nous on a gardé nos positions
aujourd'hui on en 2020 oui puisqu'il
faut le rappeler est effectivement à 7
ce second tour ne concernait que 13% des
communes un électeur sur trois étaient
concernés par cette élection au premier
tour les républicains ont donc fait à
peu près ce qu'ils avaient fait en 2014
néanmoins on le voit là les verts aussi
font une forte poussée ce soir les
républicains qui ne sont pas forcément
écolo ou est ce que c'est un est ce que
c'est un tort selon vous vous savez
écouter n'y a pas de pas forcément écolo
on est tous intéressés par ce qui se
passe par la planète
après nous on a des thématiques qu'on
défense
cité sur l'immigration sur la sécurité
sur l'économie sur l'emploi selon
l'autorité
et je pense que on a approuvé aussi à
travers christian jacob que les
républicains sur la première force
politique aujourd'hui dans la vie
politique française puisque on a
remporté ces élections municipales comme
vous disais c'est dire tout à l'heure
73% des villes avaient déjà été réglées
notamment lors du premier tour on a
profité dans les autres villes
aujourd'hui on attend les autres billes
qui vont arriver notamment marseille
qu'on attend avec bordeaux mais c'est
aussi surtout un désaveu pour le parti
présidentiel admis qu'en marche qui est
qui a montré encore une fois que c'était
un parti ancré dans les territoires et
que la seule force politique ancrée dans
le territoire aujourd'hui c'est le
républicain est ce que l'alliance avec
la république en marche a été fructueuse
pour pour les républicains
je parlerai pas d'alliance avec les
publics en marche je pense que sur les
plans locaux certains certaines
personnes ont décidé de de salies de
soutenir mais nous on n'a jamais voulu
me alliance avec eux partiraient le butô
marche alors pardonnez moi c'était fait
dit qu' on va prendre la direction de
lille où martine aubry serait de peu en
tête devant le candidat europe ecologie
les verts selon les dernières
informations martine aubry qui s'apprête
à prendre la parole en direct quelques
mots ce soir d'abord vous dire quand je
regarde les élections les résultats ces
élections municipales partout en france
il ya d'abord une immense tristesse pour
moi qui me suis engagé dans le
syndicalisme dans l'associatif est en
politique depuis maintenant très
longtemps comme certains me l'ont appelé
une très grande tristesse de voir ce
taux d'abstention il faut il faut tout
ce qu'on s'interroge retrouver la
politique la vraie avec des valeurs des
projets et apprendre à chacun et à
chaque citoyen repenser collectif à
repenser une société on en a tellement
besoin aujourd'hui
donc voilà la deuxième chose évidemment
un immense bonheur
il ya tant de choses encore à faire dans
cette ville avec cette magnifique équipe
que je remerciais avec tous les
militants avec les lillois qui nous font
confiance aujourd'hui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui tellement de choses à faire dans
cette crise qui s'annonce encore plus
forte pour réduire les inégalités
sociales je n'ai jamais oublié ce qui
est le fondement de mon engagement et
pour évidemment aller encore plus vite
dans la transition écologique
je voudrais dire que cette abstention
elle est énorme alors que tous les
candidats et je salue toutes les équipes
et tous les candidats ont fait une
grande campagne sont allés partout et il
faut redire cela pour se dire que faire
de la politique aujourd'hui c'est pas
simple et l'engagement de chacun doit
être respectée je voudrais dire aussi
que j'ai entendu j'allais dire je le
savais mais je l'aï entendu encore plus
fort le message partout en france sur la
nécessité de cette transition écologique
c'est ma conviction croyez bien que nous
tous ici et je le dis particulièrement
et stéphane chevalier et à ses
colistiers
nous n'oublierons pas ce qu on dit
partout en france et ici à lille les 39
% des lillois qui ont voté pour eux même
si je pense que les 40% qui ont voté
pour nous sont aussi favorables à la
transition écologique
voilà je crois qu'il faut aussi le dire
aux angles
[Applaudissements]
m
voilà donc transition écologique lutte
contre les inégalités sociales
plus encore de démocratie et puis une
ville qui continue à être en mouvement
parce qu'autrement on ne crée pas
d'emplois on n'est pas du tout auprès de
ceux qui sont les plus fragiles
voilà ce qui va constituer notre travail
pour les six ans qui viennent encore une
fois en essayant de faire en sorte que
tous ceux qui se sont exprimés
aujourd'hui puissent effectivement
continuer à travailler pour lille parce
qu'on a tous cette passion pour la ville
voilà je m'arrêterai là mais je voudrais
remercier tous les agents de la ville
qui ont permis à la fois l'organisation
dans les bureaux de vote dans des
conditions exceptionnelles de sécurité
je crois qu'il faut le dire et puis tous
ceux qui aujourd'hui nous permettent
d'être là et puis merci aux lilloises et
aux lillois osé les oiseaux et les mois
aux lommoises aux lommois ils peuvent
compter sur nous tous sur cette belle
équipe qui m'entoure et que je remercie
très chaleureusement
voilà bonne soirée la partie mobile qui
réagit après les estimations à lille ce
que la première fois qu'il n'avait pas
d'alliance depuis 1977 avec les
écologistes on va faire un point avec
vous justement sur ses résultats
concernant à la fois les écologistes
mais aussi le parti socialiste thomas
bonnet oui donc à lille les écologistes
battu sur le fil on parle de quelques
centaines de voix d'écart c'est à dire
que le
les résultats en tout cas les
estimations sont très serrés dans la
ville de lille ce qui était là encore
loin d'être acquis il ya surtout deux
grandes surprises dans les premières
estimations qui nous parviennent ce sont
les villes de bordeaux et de marseille
bordeaux d'abord où le candidat pierre
hurmic candidat europe ecologie les
verts seraient devant nicolas florian le
candidat les républicains successeur
d'alain juppé soutenu rallier en tout
cas par le candidat de la république en
marche
victoire donc a priori pour les
écologistes à bordeaux est également à
marseille c'est là un basculement assez
historique puisque michel rubio la
soeurette en tête
plus de dix points d'avancé selon les
premières estimations une candidate
michel rubio là qui a fait une alliance
de la gauche mais qui est aussi une
candidate d'europe écologie les verts en
tout cas qui est une candidate
écologiste à la base on parle aussi de
lyon où là encore c'est un candidat
écologiste en l'occurrence grégory
doucet qui serait en tête largement en
tête même grégory doucet devant frédéric
devant yann cucherat pardon à lyon donc
trois grandes villes peut être acquise à
la cause des candidats d'europe écologie
les verts ça devrait aussi être le cas à
grenoble au premier tour le maire
sortant eric piolle avait atteint 46 68
% des voix n'a pas encore d'estimation
sur la ville de grenoble mais a priori
sauf énorme surprise le maire sortant
d'europe écologie verts devrait donc
être reconduit
faut quand même noter également qu'à
strasbourg la candidate d'europe
ecologie-les verts est en tête devant le
candidat de la république aux marches
donc grosse percée des écologistes qui
semble mieux résister en réalité à
l'abstention très forte on rappelle à
l'instigation de l'abstention 60% par
exemple à lille je voulais vous donner
ce chiffre à lille les estimations sur
l'abstention font état de 68 %
d'abstention ce qui est absolument
gigantesque dans la ville de lille et on
a d'ailleurs entendu dans le discours de
martine aubry il ya finalement qu'à
toulouse en tout cas que la percée
écologiste a eu des limites puisque jean
luc moudenc qui est à la fois soutenue
par les républicains et par la
république en marche serait en tête
devant le candidat écologiste antoine
maurice à l'eau
vous parliez de marseille thomas on va
en parler justement avec stéphane ticket
jean claude gaudin qui tenait la ville
depuis
195 stéphane tiki ça c'est une déception
pour la droite
écoutez c'est vrai que les résultats a
priori aujourd'hui à marseille n'est pas
satisfaisant on attend encore de savoir
comment ça va se terminer mais rien
n'est encore fait parce que martine
vassal emprunt de chauffage ou troisième
tour à marseille et il ya un secteur
dans lequel on n'a pas encore les
résultats je crois doute attiser
certaines secteurs
rappelons aussi une chose qui est
importante la droite a gagné face à
stéphane ravier qui était le candidat du
front national alors qu'il était maire
sortant dont certains secteurs
pourraient conquérir à marseille et pour
répondre à votre question à votre
question précédente sur le est ce que
les républicains devraient devenir un
peu plus écologique
j'aimerais qu'elle rappelait que le
premier président la république qui a
créé un ministère de l'écologie et qui a
mis en place ce grenelle de
l'environnement il s'appelle nicolas
alors stéphane tiki anne hidalgo à la
maire de paris va s'exprimer après sa
victoire avec 52% des voix selon les
premières estimations
[Applaudissements]
merci merci paris charte parisienne
parisien
[Musique]
aujourd'hui vous m'avez accordé votre
confiance pour être à nouveau maire de
paris les circonstances exceptionnelles
de qui entoure ce deuxième tour de
l'élection municipale rendre ce moment
très particulier
je veux remercier l'ensemble des
citoyennes et des citoyens qui se sont
déplacés aujourd'hui malgré la crise du
coronavirus ainsi que toutes celles et
tous ceux qui se sont mobilisés pour que
cette élection puisse se dérouler dans
les meilleures conditions
par cet acte vous avez montrer notre
attachement votre attachement à notre
démocratie car au delà des circonstances
le débat démocratique a eu lieu et les
électeurs ont tranché
vous avez choisi l'espoir vous avez
choisi le rassemblement vous avez choisi
un pari qui respire un pari plus
agréable à vivre une ville plus
solidaire qui ne laisse personne sur le
bord du chemin
[Applaudissements]
je veux remercier david belliard ainsi
que toutes les forces qui se sont unis
dès le premier tour autour de notre
projet et qui ont permis de constituer
cette alliance écologique sociale
humaniste pour l'avenir de paris ce soir
je veux également salué agnès buzyn et
rachida dati qui ont su mener campagne
en défendant leurs convictions j'espère
que nous pourrons travailler ensemble
malgré nos différences dans l'intérêt
des parisiennes et des parisiens
car être maire de paris c'est être mère
de toutes les parisiens
et de tous les parisiens je souhaite que
toutes les forces qui oeuvrent au
service de nos concitoyens soit impliqué
dans la transformation de notre ville
rendue d'autant plus urgente par la
crise que nous traversons nous
expérimenterons au cours de ce mandat
d'autres manières de faire vivre la
démocratie parisienne afin de donner le
goût de l'engagement à celles et ceux
qui aiment leur ville
cette victoire a du sens parce qu'elle
est collective et je veux saluer ce soir
tous les nouveaux élus parisiens
quelle que soit leur sensibilité
politique
ce mandat d'élu local est la plus belle
des responsabilités
les parisiennes et les parisiens auront
au cours des six années qui viennent
besoin de nous avec mon équipe nous
serons là je suis particulièrement ému
ce soir je pense bien sûr à toutes
celles et ceux qui m'ont permis de
devenir la femme que je suis je pense à
ceux qui m'ont inspiré je pense aux
parisiennes et aux parisiens qui m'ont
toujours soutenu
je pense à mes amis à ma famille je
pense à mon père arrivé en france avec
la république en idéal et qui voulait
que ses filles le réalise
je crois qu'il serait heureux
aujourd'hui fier que sa fille à son tour
porte l'idéal républicain pour
l'ensemble des parisiennes et des
parisiens
votre confiance m'oblige avec vous nous
bâtirons le pari de demain un pari qui
donne les moyens à ses services publics
pour qu'ils puissent exercer leurs
missions en particulier pour la santé
des parisiennes et des parisiens
un pari qui permet à chacune et chacun
de changer sa manière de vivre de mieux
se déplacer de mieux s'alimenter avec
comme valeurs communes
le respect de notre environnement un
pari solidaire qui aident celles et ceux
qui en ont le plus besoin
un pari de la différence qui combat
toutes les discriminations
un pari qui donne une véritable chance à
sa jeunesse et qui lui donne les clés
pour agir
nous serons là avec eux pour leur donner
les clés
un pari qui accompagne toutes les forces
vives de notre ville pour soutenir
transformer notre économie faire
renaître ce pari que nous aimons tant ce
pari que nous avons en commun c'est ma
vision de l'action politique
un engagement sincère une responsabilité
entière être à la hauteur de la
confiance que vous avez placée en nous
pour cela j'aurais besoin de vous car
tous ensemble nous pouvons changer les
choses et bâtir notre avenir un avenir
en commun et croyez moi
croyez moi c'est à venir sera à la
hauteur de nos espérances alors vivre
les parisiennes vivent les parisiens et
vive paris et merci voilà anne hidalgo
qui vient de s'exprimer alors qu'il
serait réélu avec 5 52% des voix dans la
capitale selon les premières estimations
et stéphane tiki secrétaire général
adjoint de droite libre est avec nous
alors europe ecologie les verts c'est a
fait une alliance avec le parti
socialiste à paris la république en
marche n'a pas fait d'alliances avec les
républicains rachida dati pour vous a
fait une belle campagne
rachida dati a fait une campagne
exceptionnelle elle a été le soleil dans
cette campagne qui s'est battu pour
défendre à la fois ses idées sur le
terrain mais aussi avec le fonds voilà
après rappelons quand même que cette
campagne si je voudrais contexte assez
compliqué puisque pendant quelques
semaines ont été touchés par la crise y
compris des je pense que les maires
sortants comme à l'été à nidau était aux
affaires nous a permis aussi de pouvoir
permettre ce genre de réélection après
on est républicain
les dix stations en vélo pour sa
victoire et les parisiens ont tranché
maintenant je pense que cette victoire
n'est pas
vraiment une très belle victoire parce
que c'est quand même avant tout la
victoire de l'abstention
ce conte aura tous les parisiens qui
sont pas allés voter paris fait partie
des villes dans lequel il ya le moins de
d'électeurs qui se sont déplacés je
pense qu'il va redonner aux six novillos
par les termes de voter parce que je
pense que de l'extension aujourd'hui est
vraiment fun
merci beaucoup d'avoir partagé votre
analyse sur notre plateau je rappelle
que vous êtes secrétaire général adjoint
de la droite libre et on va partir tout
de suite à perpignan mahiaoui perpignan
où le rassemblement national a raflé la
ville justement aux républicains nadège
abderrazak vous êtes sur place que les
l'ambiance autour de vous m'écoutez
l'ambiance au sein du qg s'est calmé et
les soutiens et bien se sont déplacés à
quelques rues d'ici place arago pour et
bien a commencé à célébrer cette
victoire de louis aliot à perpignan je
suis avec jérôme rivière des eurodéputés
du rassemblement national président de
la délégation française au parlement
européen du groupe identité et
démocratie racontez-moi un peu ce votre
réaction au sujet de cette victoire de
louis aliot à perpignan et que j'ai
d'abord je suis extrêmement
reconnaissant aux habitants de perpignan
perpignanais d'avoir permis cette
victoire d'abord parce que c'est une
belle victoire pour leur ville ils ont
écrit une page d'histoire ils ont libéré
perpignan d'une municipalité qui ne
fonctionnait pas mais surtout ils ont
démontré qu'ils étaient capables de
retrouver leur liberté la liberté de
voter contre l'escroquerie du front
républicain
pendant longtemps nous a expliqué qu'il
fallait marginaliser les
les élus et les électeurs du
rassemblement national et le travail
formidable de louis a été de permettre
cette victoire large victoire 53 % qui
éclaire le chemin pour demain les
élections départementales les élections
régionales mais surtout l'élection
présidentielle de 2022 n'auront plus mûr
cette escroquerie morale politique d'un
front républicain
nous pouvons gagner sur nos idées dans
un combat face à face un combat qui n'a
pas toujours été loyal parce que le
maire sortant n'était pas un adversaire
loyal louis l'a remporté et je m'en
félicite et je remercie encore une fois
les perpignanais petites escroqueries au
sujet de ce front républicain qui a été
mise en place par les marcheurs et les
écologistes ici à perpignan escroquerie
c'est un terme qui a aussi repris louis
aliot tout à l'heure c'est pas un peu
fort quand même comme terme non parce
qu'il s'agit effectivement d'une
escroquerie morale et politique
il est vous avez des listes qui se
combattent les unes contre les autres
vous avez ici un candidat en marche qui
se combattent qui combattait monsieur
pujol avec des mots terribles des mots
bien pire que ce qu'a pu employer le
noyau qui au lendemain du premier tour
dire mais finalement non
je vais appeler à voter pour le maire
donc c'est se moquer des électeurs on ne
peut pas expliquer que quelqu'un qui a
été critiquée avec des mots terribles
avec des points et des sujets précis
peut demain être une solution aux
principes que nous ne serions pas
républicain ce n'est pas vrai les élus
et les électeurs du rassemblement
national et des listes soutenues par
grand sablon nationale sont des
françaises et des français qui sont tjrs
aiment leur pays qu'ils aiment les
projets qu'on leur présente et qui
veulent simplement manifesté par leur
vote leur liberté de choisir en
démocratie le chemin qu'ils souhaitent
tracé est donc cette escroquerie c'était
tenté de faire croire qu'il n'y avait
pas de choix et qu'il y avait une sorte
d'obligation à soutenir un candidat
quelle que soit sa nature politique
contre le candidat du rassemblement
national
aujourd'hui c'est fini ça ne marche plus
et ça ne marchera plus louis aliot aura
la lourde tâche de faire mieux ici à
perpignan cette élection de louis aliot
à perpignan elle va elle va servir
d'exemple pour le rassemblement national
pour les années à suivre ça peut
déterminer beaucoup de choses à l'avenir
c'est effectivement très important dans
la mesure où nous devons démontrer ce
qu'on fait d'ailleurs les maires
sortants vous savez que ce soit fréjus
ou hénin beaumont nous avions des mères
la dernière fois qu'ils avaient trop
triomphé lors des élections municipales
ils ont été réélu dès le premier tour au
mois de mai au mois de mars
donc c'est bien la preuve que les villes
que nous emportons sont bien gérées et
que les électeurs adhère donc je suis
certain que louis sera faire la même
chose
c'est une taxe plus haut parce que
perpignan est une très grande ville
inséré au milieu d'une d'une
agglomération importante mais par
ailleurs louis et quelque part le
symbole de ce localisme que nous
défendons vous savez nous souhaitons
mettre un terme à cette mondialisation
effrénée qui nous a emmenés dans cette
dans cette crise du coc vide il faut
bien le dire où nous avons découvert à
cette occasion qu'un certain nombre de
nos industries et et de délocaliser que
l'absence de frontières nous mettez en
grande difficulté par la présence d'un
élu fortement enracinée symbolique dans
une grande ville nous mettrons en
pratique tout c'est toutes ces
politiques que nous souhaitons appliquer
sur le plan national
donc oui c'est une force de symbole très
fort et louis aliot est un personnage
central au sein du rassemblement
national elle son élection conforte ce
ce localisme que nous voulons présenter
et qui sera la réponse sérieuse aux
projets d'europe écologie les verts dont
on entend parler aujourd'hui mais qui
eux sont des mondialistes forcené qui
préfèrent continuer dans le modèle
d'ultralibéralisme que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui ou qui nous propose plutôt
une sorte de décroissance dont on ne
veut pas la réalité c'est un projet
ancré dans les territoires et et louis
en est un très beau symbole c'est quoi
la patte du rassemblement national au
niveau local à quoi va ressembler la
politique municipale de louis
aliot quelle marge de manoeuvre vous
avez à ce niveau-là et goûté à l'or sur
le dossier même deux des dossiers de
perpignan je suis pas de perpignan donc
je ne connais pas les dossiers mais ce
que j'ai c'est que louis fera d'abord
c'est qu'il
il aura à coeur de servir les intérêts
de tous les perpignanais et non pas ceux
d'un clan ce qui a marqué la même une
amende de la mandature précédente et la
municipalité précédente
c'est qu'il y avait vraiment le
sentiment de prendre les citoyens pour
des consommateurs politique c'est à dire
qu'en fonction des communautés
il leur donnait tel petit avantage c'est
le petit subventions pour essayer
d'acheter les électeurs c'est un système
qui est qui et qui est absolument
révoltant et qui d'ailleurs a montré ses
limites parce que les électeurs ne
veulent pas être traités comme des
clients souhaitent accéder comme des
citoyens et lala louis l'a dit tout à
l'heure dans son dans son dans son
intervention qu'il souhaite traiter
l'ensemble des perpignanais comme des
citoyens et c'est le plus important
merci beaucoup jérôme rivière d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes heureux député du
rassemblement national et président du
groupe identité et démocratie au
parlement européenne donc vous l'avez
entendu j'ai romain rivière qui croit
beaucoup en la politique de de louis
aliot à perpignan
merci beaucoup nadège pour toutes ces
précisions et on continue bien sûr à
suivre cette soirée avec vous on va
rejoindre nos invités à présent à
dieynaba diop porte-parole du parti
socialiste avec nous également à présent
ludovic de la rg expert en communication
bonsoir à tous les deux merci beaucoup
d'être en direct sur rt france tout
d'abord une question pour vous 10 naba
diop
vous vous faites partie du parti
socialiste lyne réaction à la victoire
de dender go à paris nous sommes
évidemment ravis de conserver harry ce
fut une belle campagne
anne hidalgo a été soutenu c est une
belle récompense du travail qu'elle a
menée durant le mandat précédent et nous
sommes heureux de gagner aussi avec les
écologistes et donc d'avoir fait un beau
rassemblement de la gauche y est vous
êtes actuellement à marseille marseille
qui est en passe aussi de basculer c'est
le printemps marseillais nous français
ce soir
oui j'y crois très fortement et cela
couvent
encore une fois que lorsque la gauche
est rassemblée elle est capable d'être
en responsabilité est de gagner
largement
je pense que c'est aussi ce que nous
devons retenir de ces municipales c'est
que c'est le rassemblement de la gauche
qui fera qu elle continuera d'avoir des
responsabilités et surtout qu'elle
retrouvera une place importante dans le
coeur des français
on le voit avec ces élections
municipales la gauche reprend des
couleurs
les partis traditionnels finalement ne
sont pas mort comme on l'a cru en 2019
avec les élections européennes
oui tout à fait et je pense que c'est
surtout on montre en fait ici que l'élu
de proximité qui est un conseiller
municipal à quai le maire garde toute
son importance et qu'effectivement la
gauche et les partis dits
traditionalistes sont loin d'être
enterrée au contraire ils ont une carte
à jouer mais ce qu'il faut retenir c'est
que elle doit être rassemblé et c'est
aussi aujourd'hui la victoire d'une
gauche différentes qui s'allie avec les
citoyens et les citoyennes
alors avec nous également ludovic de
l'air je vous êtes expert en
communication alors justement une
question une campagne pour le second
tour uniquement sur les réseaux sociaux
et dans les médias est ce que cela a pu
jouer comme mode de campagne selon vous
bah en fait ça signifie surtout que
c'était pas une campagne
donc on est très loin d'une élection on
est dans la continuité d'un président
qui impose sa volonté à 66 millions de
français alors qu'il a été choisi par
8,6 d'entre eux on n'appelle pas ça la
démocratie
c'est une élection c'est la source de
légitimité pour un élu ce qui fait que
les représentants du peuple qui l'a élu
là aujourd'hui on à 60% d'abstention
donc c'est la fin non seulement les
partis traditionnels mais mal de la vème
république
enfin faut qu'on arrête ça rime plus à
rien il ya des gens qui sont exprimées
depuis trois ans dans la rue qui ont
même été matraqué pour ça on leur a tiré
dessus et est aujourd'hui n'ont pas été
voter parce qu'en fait ils ne sont pas
écoutés ne sont pas entendues donc c'est
un désaveu complet de la classe
politique quelle joie pour vous que ce
n'est pas la crise qui a joué justement
sur cette abstention
mais on a tous vu des quais de seine
depuis 15 jours les gens sont dehors
donc on va pas me dire que là c'est la
peur du virus qui ont fait que les gens
pas été votée c'était gentil manquent
pas et écouter la convention sit in sur
le climat est déjà un camouflet parce
que ils sont déjà repoussé dans leurs 22
par par edouard philippe et par emmanuel
macron il avait gardé sous le coude pour
demain donc là évidemment comme un
signal fort qu'il a enfin entendu parce
qu'en fait l'écologie en france ça fait
des années ça préoccupe beaucoup de
monde ça fait des années que des
mouvements le clame haut et fort et même
au local donc donc donc c'est une
découverte ce soir pour l'éditorialiste
de deux de ses huit et de bfm et pour
notre président mais en fait ça fait
longtemps qu'on sait que l'écologie est
un sujet qui préoccupe les gens et puis
surtout l'art du coup on a une
merveilleuse percée d'europe écologie
les verts et ses alliés et l'important
dans la france et ses alliés et j'espère
qu'ils vont mieux se comporter que la
façon qu'on dise qu'on porte au
parlement européen qui vont respecter
leur parole et les programmes donc là on
rentre dans une phase qui cogne très
très très complexe et très chahuté parce
que 60% d'abstention ce n'est plus une
élection dont un premier tour fantoche
en second tour fantoche c'est quand même
très compliqué en termes de légitimité
mes félicitations évidemment tous ces
points ont été élus personnellement je
félicite l'équipe de lyon s'est pas
faite auprès d'eux à cause du coc vide
et je suis très content leur victoire et
à l'équipe de lauzès que je rejoins la
fin de semaine
petit village qui a monté une liste
citoyenne mais hormis les féliciter et
même un vrai problème démocratique c'est
60% aux imagine fonds n'a jamais à tort
a atteint 100 et non on ne peut pas dire
que c'est le vide il faut arrêter les
bêtises les rues sont pleines les bars
sont pleins les restaurants sont pleins
donc on va pas dire que les parisiens
par exemple invités cette semaine à
paris donc je ne peux parler que de
paris mais on ne peut pas dire qu'elle
parisiens n'ont pas été votées par peur
de virus
non ils n'ont pas été voter parce que
c'est surtout les classes populaires qui
n'ont pas été votées en les grandes
villes donc des gens qui ne s'interprète
qu'ils se sentent pas écoutés
même s'ils vont risquer leur vie dans la
rue tous les week-ends à se faire tirer
dessus par la police donc nous que ces
gens là n'ont pas été votées c'est un
signal extrêmement important que notre
démocratie ne fonctionne plus il faut
absolument réformer rénover notre
démocratie et redonner la parole aux
citoyens et les citoyennes qui gagne
c'est un très très bon signal il va
falloir respecter cette parole parce que
si on fait des déçus dans les grandes
villes sur lequel les lits citoyennes
sont arrivés en tête ont pas déclencher
un mouvement
un retour de bâton qui sera d'autant
plus violent on est à un moment capital
de yahoo et de notre démocratie
emmanuel macron a réagi ce soir il dit
qu'il va apporter deyres des réponses
fortes à sa convention pour le climat
c'est une manière de répondre aussi à
cette percée des verts aujourd'hui et et
à cette défaite globale depuis le
premier tour en tout cas pour la
république en marche moi j'ai travaillé
assez proche de cette convention pour le
climat depuis un an et demi
en fait il cherche à la faire taire
depuis un an et demi un je le dis très
sincèrement parce que évidemment les
mesures ne l'intéressent pas et
contredit complètement sa politique donc
il va apporter des réponses fortes comme
il le fait depuis deux ans c'est à dire
rien on va encore brasser du vent
on verra on voir des gens déçus et je
pense que -lyon travail remarquable
qu'il a fait avec cette convention a
amené à un programme extrêmement 100 c
est ce qui sort de la convention climat
est admirable vraiment c'est admirable
c'est d'ailleurs compatible avec un
stand de programmes qu'il est présenté à
la presse l'ancien enfant tout cas un
mais mais là on va voir ce qu'il va
apporter demain mais on connaît par
coeur maintenant on n'écoute même plus
on n'écoute même plus il ya qu'à voir
ses scores d'audience quand il parle à
la télé on a même pu voter dans sa
france donc y aura bien un attrait
macron un avant et un après macron inns
& prom il république rétabli une
république exemplaire à un barrage
contre le front national
grâce à lui le front national à une
première grande ville en france c'est
historique et on n'a jamais eu autant de
records d'abstention en france
dire qu'il a réussi à désintéresser à
dégoûter tous les français de la
politique alors qu'on a des millions de
personnes dans la rue toutes les
semaines donc il arrive un tour de force
on verra ce qu'il va faire demain alors
ludovic de l'air j'avoue rester avec
nous dieynaba diop également vous reste
avec nous avant on va faire un point
avec vous thomas bonnin finalement pari
manqué pour la république en marche mais
c'était plus ou moins attendu la
république aux marches reparti avec ces
élections municipales ne serait pas
véritablement une réussite puisque le
parti présidentiel ne bénéficient pas
vraiment d'ancrage local puisque le
parti le mouvement était constituée
surtout dans le cadre de l'élection
présidentielle de 2017 et ça se
concrétise réellement avec les résultats
avec plusieurs stratégies parfois des
stratégies différentes qui ont été mises
en place dans différentes villes et il
faut bien l'avouer que ça a été assez
rarement fructueux on commence d'abord
par la ville de strasbourg où le
candidat de la république en marche
s'était allié avec le candidat les
républicains pour faire front commun
face à la candidature d'europe écologie
les verts safari perdu puisque c'est
jeanne bars égayant la candidate
d'europe écologie les verts qui est
arrivé en tête qui a d'ailleurs fait
part de sa fierté c'était une ville
pourtant qui pouvait être une des
conquêtes de la majorité présidentielle
dans ces élections municipales ce n'est
pas le cas idem à lyon et à bordeaux où
des front commun avait été constituée de
la même façon avec des alliances avec
les candidats les républicains cela n'a
pas fonctionné puisque à lyon et à
bordeaux ce sont là aussi des candidats
europe ecologie les verts qui sont en
tête selon les premières estimations
revenant également sur paris on sait une
campagne très compliqué pour le parti
présidentiel avec le désistement de
benjamin griveaux et puis agnès buzyn
l'ancien ministre de la santé qui selon
les estimations qui nous parviennent ce
soir ne récolterait qu'à peine 13 entre
13 et 15% des suffrages ce qui est
évidemment en deçà des attentes du parti
présidentiel qui au début de cette
campagne des municipales il ya quelques
mois espérait pouvoir conquérir les
villes de paris et de lyon on est
évidemment loin loin du compte alors
pour se consoler il ya évidemment les
résultats d'edouard philippe au havre
réélu assez largement ce soir et aussi
la situation à toulouse où les élus au
havre ce soir et puis à toulouse où jean
luc moudenc le maire sortant avait fait
alliance là aussi avec le parti
présidentiel et l'ail il a été réélu ce
soir si bête ndiaye la porte parole du
gouvernement affirme ce soir nous
éprouvons une déception et manama contre
son côté qui se dit préoccupé par la
forte abstention dont évidemment le
parti en marche
aphatie ce soir pour ce second tour pari
manqué donc magalys merci beaucoup
olivier on va en parler avec vous deviez
labbadia pour vous c'est ce fort taux
d'abstention est préoccupant c'est ce
qu'a dit jean luc mélenchon ce soir 1 il
me dit que c'est un danger pour la
démocratie
oui je je rejoins les commentateurs
évidemment
lorsqu'on est responsable politique est
d'autant plus lorsqu'on est élu local
on ne peut que s'inquiéter de
l'abstention grandissant comme ont
atteint un taux historique et
effectivement il faut situer c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut prendre en
compte
on ne peut pas ignorer que 60%
d'abstention il y a un vrai malaise
démocratique dans notre pays
et effectivement je pense que cette
défiance envers la classe politique est
en grande partie due aux à ce
gouvernement qui a manqué à sa promesse
celle d'une république exemplaire celle
d'une république qui écoute les gens se
sont sentis délaissés abandonné voire
même méprisé par le pouvoir en place et
ça se traduit malheureusement par non
seulement un décrochage important de la
république en marche
qui de toute façon je n'avais pas
d'ancrage local et ça s'est vu lors de
ces élections municipales mais aussi par
une abstention record
parce que les personnes se disent que ça
ne vaut pas vraiment la peine de se
déplacer aux urnes et c'est vraiment
très préoccupant on sait pas la crise
sanitaire c'est pas la peur du virus qui
a fait que les gens ne se sont pas
déplacés aujourd'hui il y a de cela mais
je pense qu'il peut aussi prendre en
ligne de compte le fait que vous avez
déjà vu des mouvements sociaux assez
important qu évoqué tout à l'heure
l'autre invité moi je pense qu'il ya
deux facteurs il y a la peur du couronne
un virus parce qu'on nous a répété
pendant des semaines et des mois que
c'était un virus mortel qui ne fallait
pas à sortir de chez soi
et même si effectivement dans certaines
grandes villes les gens reprennent le
cours de leur vie normale vous avez
encore beaucoup d'endroits où les gens
n'osent pas sortir où les gens
continuent d'être ruiné parce que ils
ont peur d'avoir comment dirais-je une
seconde vague donc geipan alors merci
diana dieu on essaiera de vous retrouver
petits problèmes techniques mais on va
retrouver par téléphone sébastien chenu
porte parole du rassemblement national
ancien maire-adjoint de
mauvais sébastien chenu bonsoir bonsoir
alors peut-être votre première réaction
notamment après cette victoire très à
perpignan louis aliot bien sûr être
mixées il a dit qu'on était surtout sa
fille
la fin de ce qui était appelé le front
républicain cette espèce de pacotille et
qu'on me sort à chaque élection 1 qui a
vocation en sorte que des gens qui eux
en tirant des tièdes politiques oublient
leurs convictions les kilos d'héroïne et
de parler re pour pouvoir faire barrage
à sa part des électeurs de perpignan ont
décidé que le front républicain n'était
pas acceptable que c'était une magouille
politique elle ne marche plus
aujourd'hui grâce au national en même
temps quitteront perpignan a su et
bastien ce nul on l'a vu fort taux
d'abstention près de 60% c'est
historique c'est favorable à votre parti
donc c'est surtout défavorable à la
démocratie cette abstention elle ne
tombe pas du ciel en réalité le
gouvernement nous a démontré non
seulement qu'il était incapable
d'organiser dans de bons terre lune
élections municipales l'abstention était
un des marqueurs qui permet de dire
cette élection il réussit ou pas or elle
ne l'est pas démocratiquement parlant de
l'autre côté sont pas du ciel dans le
sens où les français sont écoeurés des
politiques qui sont menées mais surtout
se détournent des urnes parce que ils
ont le sentiment d'avoir été trahis par
emmanuel macron par son gouvernement ce
qui leur avait promis la sécurité qui
dans le premier la souveraineté qui leur
avait promis un tas de choses et cet
échec sanitaires économiques sociales
qui est celui des modèles ba compte
eh bien ils invitent les françaises
détourné des sommes pour vous c'est un
vote sanction quelque sorte pour le
parti présidentiel à bas ce soir
évidemment le parti présidentiel prend
une claque magistrale 0,15 d'hérouville
on peut pas dire que la république en
marche a gagné une ville zéro ville
gagner des villes perdues surtout
lorsqu'il son allié américain
oui c'est par votre sanction pour la
république en marche
c'est aussi une 500 pour les
républicains qui perdent des grandes
villes marseille bordeaux tu roules etc
qui ont été la plupart du temps allié et
mais elle va compliquer ont soutenu ces
politiques
c'est en tous les cas une sanction pour
la politique qui est menée par emmanuel
macron et ceux qui le soutiennent alors
sébastien chenu on lisait forte poussée
des écologistes ce soir qu'est ce que ça
révèle pour vous cette poussée verte
je crois que les électeurs il ya tant de
choses
ils attendent d'abord de la sécurité de
la souveraineté être protéger leur
identité leur sécurité et datant d'aussi
que soient prises en compte leurs
demandes de l'écologie de localisme et
qu'on en finisse avec ce mondialisme qui
avait fabriqué aux coupes du monde
des éléments qui sont vendus ici en
france et bien puisqu'il ne trouve pas
ces deux réponses la sécurité et le
localisme dans la politique de la grande
île se tourner vers ceux qui à perpignan
où vont leurs répondre sur la sécurité
dans une ville qui en a bien besoin ils
votent pour le rassemblement national et
vont se tourner vers des d'écologistes
dans d'autres villes où les
problématiques environnementales sont
importantes et bien voilà c'est ça ce
que cette élection veux dire c'est qu'il
ya des demandes fortes dans le pays
elles ne sont pas satisfaites et qu'on
est en train de dessiner un nouveau
clivage demain un clivage entre le
rassemblement national et puis
probablement les verts merci sébastien
chenu d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes porte parole du
rassemblement national et on va fondre
tout de suite la direction de paris au
quartier général de campagne de rachida
dati qui a perdu ce soir la mairie de
paris pour rejoindre notre reporter
monahan ou dès lors monaco vous êtes sur
place quelle est l'ambiance
les choix
tout et magali l'ambiance est plutôt
calme et ceci enfin malgré tout on a
quand même du monde qui commencent à
arriver dès des sympathisants mais
également la famine rachida dati ses
soeurs vous pouvez le voir juste
derrière moi la famille qui est posté
juste devant cette vitrine 6 et puis
juste à ma gauche ici il y aller et la
horde de journalistes qui attend
toujours de pied ferme à rachida dati
qui n'est toujours pas arrivée elle son
qg donc toujours pas à d'allocutions
toujours pas de mots de la part de
rachida dati qui est loin derrière anne
hidalgo il faut le dire avec 32% des
voix selon harris interactive avec et
anne hidalgo qui la devance avec 50,2 et
cette défaite écrasante de la république
en marché avec agnès buzyn de 16% ces
chiffres sont susceptibles de changer
tout au long de la soirée parlons
maintenant du taux d'abstention à paris
qui est de 64% c'est énorme et du jamais
vu historique
grosse déception pour la droite à paris
alors de rachida dati n'a pas gagné la
la la la ville mais en tout cas elle et
elle a été réélue maire du 7e
arrondissement dès le premier tour
christian jacob lui s'est exprimé je
vous propose de l'écouter
on peut dire ce soir c'est que nous
renouons avec la victoire c'est une
grande et belle victoire pour les
républicains pour leur allié puisque ce
sera entre 50 et 60% des villes de plus
de 9000 habitants qui vont être gagnée
par les maires les républicains et leur
leurs alliés donc une belle victoire
après trois années où on a connu
beaucoup d'échecs présidentielle
législative européenne
on renoue avec la victoire et on renoue
sur le terrain c'est-à-dire avec cet
ancrage territorial qui est qui et dans
notre adn
christian jacob avait plutôt positive
ceci étant il ya quelques villes que les
républicains ont perdu par l'ons par
exemple la cité phocéenne qui est depuis
des années depuis un quart de siècle à
droite et bien michel ribes ruby rola
l'emportent avec 39 1,9 pour cent nous
ici notre côté on attend toujours
rachida dati de pied ferme devant son qg
boulevard sébastopol à paris
merci beaucoup mona et on reviendra vers
vous évidemment lorsque rachida dati
viendra à son qg de campagne
un ludovic de l'aerf je me tourne vers
vous à présent vous êtes expert en
communication on a eu une campagne assez
atypique trois semaines c'est long trois
semaines sans pouvoir d'ailleurs avoir
de contact vraiment proche avec la
population est-ce que ça a faussé selon
vous les résultats
ça dépend ce qu'on entend parfois si les
résultats en fait là ce qu'on entend
depuis tout à l'heure et j'ai eu
plusieurs chaînes allumé un côté cédé
interprétation nationale de ce qui s'est
passé ça au plan local comme christian
jacob dit on renoue avec la victoire en
fait saillant est rien compris sire que
ça que je suis désolé de le marteler on
à 60% d'abstention c'est une catastrophe
démocratique vraiment c'est une
catastrophe n'est pas une donnée
comptable c'est une catastrophe et on a
quand même une campagne qui n'a pas eu
lieu
donc des pouvoirs publics qui ont refusé
ils aimeraient bourse clair que les
pouvoirs publics ont refusé de faire une
élection digne
légitime crédible et on a une réponse
qui est 60% d'abstention donc une n'y a
pas eu de campagne le temps une campagne
c'est le temps de la conviction
d'échangés autour de projets c'est pas
le temps on affiche des têtes sur des
affiches et les gens votent un peu comme
ils peuvent et en fonction des idées
vagues idées qu'ils ont des mouvements
qui 1
et d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que la
plupart des candidats en marche ce
n'était même pas étiquetés en marche et
malgré ça ils ont pris une branlée
donc c'était pas une campagne une
campagne c'est un truc important en fait
ce sont des projets écrit par des gens
qui vont convaincre et écouter pour
pouvoir même les modifiés pendant leur
pratique du pouvoir et le vote qui en
résultent conférer une légitimité
démocratique qui fait que nous français
citoyen nous donnons notre argent et
nous laissons la décision qui nous
incombe parce que la démocratie la
république c'est le gouvernement du
peuple par le peuple pour le peuple et
pas pour les intérêts privés donc là on
n'a aucune des données qui n'est qu'ils
n'iraient qui est réuni il ya pas une
campagne a pas eu de temps de conviction
réelle
hormis par les réseaux sociaux c'est là
qu'en fait la campagne est soumise aux
algorithmes de facebook s'efface c'est
indigne
c'est indigne on ne peut pas admettre
qu'un choix démocratique qui a été fait
en fonction des algorithmes de facebook
ça n'est pas bon et ou de twitter ça
n'est pas possible donc on a une réponse
claire c'est que les gens n'ont pas été
votés il va voir tirer des conclusions
mais des conclusions nationales
on ne peut pas élection après élection
martelé qu'il ya de plus en plus
abstentions il ne rien faire et ne pas
laisser les gens s'exprimer quand il
veut et quand il souhaite le faire par
exemple référendum d'initiative
citoyenne
c'est la réponse parfaite à au score
d'absence au conte à la sq on a des gens
qui nous disent on veut avoir plus
souvent la parole et pouvoir dire aux
gens qui dévouent leurs paroles qui ne
restent pas respectent pas leurs
engagements qu'on se passe 2 est bien là
on aurait une réponse très claire
faisons un référendum demain sur le sol
eric et on verra ce que ça va donner en
termes de taux de participation
là les gens n'étaient pas vraiment
concernés par la question qui leur a été
posée il ya malgré tout des tendances
qui se dégagent et je voulais je voulais
quand même ajouté un point somme
permettait magali il faut vraiment
connaître année
d'où le travail de sape qu'elle fait
depuis des années pour expliquer qu'une
mairie a un rôle à jouer par rapport aux
riches cherchent au réchauffement
climatique global
pour ça les récompenses est ce qu'elle
est réélu aussi parce que la campagne
était pitoyable entre dati griveaux
épuise un bon il ya quand même une voie
royale mais aussi elle a quand même à
planter c'est cette idée dans un certain
nombre de grandes agglomérations et le
travail qui est fait le travail de sape
permanent qui est fait sur il ya des
bouchons la rue de rivoli n'est plus
praticable en voiture et c est bien là
on voit que oui c'est un travail qu'il
faut mener et pour ça il faut quand même
féliciter anne hidalgo
ludovic violet vous restez avec nous
mais avant fait un point avec vous
thomas bonnet donc anne hidalgo maire de
paris élu avec 50,2 pour cent des voix
autre figure du parti socialiste élu à
lille cette fois mais martine aubry qui
aura vécu une soirée on imagine un peu
un peu compliqué puisque pendant une
bonne partie une bonne partie de la
soirée c'était par les estimations
donnaient son rival stéphane baly le
candidat écologiste en tête et puis
finalement est bien avec la fin du
dépouillement il se trouve donc martine
aubry s'offre un quatrième mandat à la
mairie de lille
l'écart entre les deux candidats est
estimé à l'heure où je vous parle à 227
voix
on imagine donc
voilà quel point ça s'est joué dans un
mouchoir de poche
il faut aussi noter que martine aubry
n'avait pas fait d'alliances avec la
liste écologiste à lille c'était la
première fois depuis 1970 cette voie
qu'elle a failli s'en mordre les doigts
et plus martine aubry était soutenu
c'était un peu plus bizarres surprenant
soutenu par la droite qui avait été
éliminé dès le premier tour
et puis la france insoumise pour sa part
n'avait pas donné de consigne de vote
voilà donc les raisons qui expliquent
cet écart très serré entre martine aubry
et et sa rivale faut noter aussi qu'à
lille les estimations de l'abstention
parle d'un chiffre autour de 68 % c'est
donc au dessus de la moyenne nationale
je propose d'écouter martine aubry kim
certes soulagé par sa victoire est
évidemment revenu sur ce taux de
participation particulièrement bas on
écoute d'abord vous dire quand je
regarde les élections les résultats ces
élections municipales partout en france
il ya d'abord une immense tristesse pour
moi qui me suis engagé dans le
syndicalisme dans l'associatif est en
politique depuis maintenant très
longtemps comme certains me l'ont
rappelé une très grande tristesse de
voir ce taux d'abstention il faut il
faut tout ce qu'on s'interroge retrouver
la politique la vraie avec des valeurs
des projets et apprendre à chacun et à
chaque citoyen repenser collectif à
repenser une société on en a tellement
besoin aujourd'hui
donc voilà la deuxième chose évidemment
un immense bonheur
il ya tant de choses encore à faire dans
cette ville avec cette magnifique équipe
que je remercie avec tous les militants
avec les lillois qui nous font confiance
aujourd'hui pour l'histoire de martine
aubry ce soir dieynaba diop quelle
quelle est votre réaction quand on voit
effectivement que pour la première fois
depuis 1977 martine aubry n'a pas fait
alliance avec les verts
d'abord pour quelles raisons et est-ce
que sans les verts vous pouvez toujours
gagner je parle des prochaines élections
évidemment escoder les alliances ou une
refondation est nécessaire selon rompre
les alliances sont ce que nous avons
c'est ce qu'a été en fait la règle pour
ces élections municipales nous avons
cherché à la faire partout
malheureusement il ya certains endroits
où
les verts ont décidé de partir seul et
c'est dommageable parce que cela prouve
encore une fois que lorsque il y a de la
division c'est la gauche qui est
perdante
je suis évidemment très heureuse que
martine aubry conserve la ville de lille
nous en aurions été bien plus heureux si
elle avait pu la conserver
avec les verts mais je pense que ce
qu'il faut retenir surtout c'est que le
parti socialiste a fait alliance partout
où c'était possible parce que nous
sommes intimement convaincus que ce
qu'il faut c'est un bloc de gauche il
faut un bloc de gauche qui serait une
alternative à une sorte de il n'ya pas
justement de choses qui soient écrites
on a voulu nous faire croire que nous
n'avions une fois qu'entre le
rassemblement national et la république
en marche force est de constater que par
exemple le gouvernement en tout cas le
parti au pouvoir a été sévèrement puni
puisque il prend une sacrée des routes
donc à nous à la gauche que nous avons
la responsabilité en tant que partis
traditionnels est aussi important que
partie historique de continuer à
chercher l'alliance de la gauche partout
où c'est possible et de conforter ce
bloc de gauche justement vienne avait un
job relier fort premier secrétaire du ps
lui parvint blog social écologique il
faut maintenant consolider sa passe par
où selon vous ça passe comme je voulais
déjà dit par une alliance à plus large
possible à gauche de toutes les forces
de gauche et bien sûr des écologistes je
pense que c'est un bloc qui en manquent
cruellement aux français et c'est un
bloc qui a été du coup
plébiscité par les français ce soir
parce que la gauche réalise un peu
partout un bon score et les socialistes
qu'on avait trop vite enterré résiste
très bien
nous avons aussi deux belles victoires
notamment à marseille je pense que c'est
emblématique de ce que peut faire la
gauche lorsqu'elle est rassemblé quand
vous dites la gauche est ce que ça
comprend la france en soumises bien sûr
il faut il n'y a pas de bonne ou de
mauvaise gauche pour moi le bleu
de gauche et un et deux ans soit quelque
chose qu'il faut rechercher et donc nous
feront alliance avec toutes les forces
de gauche
à chaque fois que c'est possible merci
beaucoup dieynaba diallo vous restez
avec nous je me tourne vers vous ludovic
de la herse justement sur cette
résurgence on va dire en tout cas de la
gauche comment est-ce que vous
l'analysez est ce que c'est le social
qui prend le dessus alors qu'on est en
crise économique après la crise
sanitaire ou français en fait il ya
plusieurs données vous savez c'est que
bon vous savez tant ce qu'on entend par
la gauche
il ya des alliances qui ont été faites
mais qui sont pas des alliances
d'étiquettes et résilience re défaite
sur les programmes des erreurs qui ont
été faites sur des contenus et ça c'est
très important
donc il va falloir et le travail
d'années doit être faite sur le travail
de ces municipalités maintenant le sens
ils vont respecter ces programmes parce
que une peut y avoir deux blocs et d'un
lionceau qu'autour de projet il faut
arrêter de parler des personnes il
faudrait de parler de parler des
étiquettes
7 / personnalisation de la vie politique
est néfaste à la démocratie il faut
parler de projet de projet de société
aujourd'hui le bilan de ces municipales
c'est que les électeurs n'ont pas fait
société et l'important c'est de faire
société
donc il faut parler de projets de
contenus il ya effectivement une lame de
fond mais depuis des années qui est
réprimée en part par beaucoup de
mouvements qui est qui et l'écologie et
surtout l'humaniste solidaire et sociale
et ça c'est un socle sur lequel il faut
s'appuyer évidemment mais sur des
programmes et donc il va pas falloir à
nouveau pérorer sur des alliances refusé
parce qu'on a en face de nous des gens
qui sont affichés parce que le da tout
le monde ne sera pas l'envers on va voir
des petits bonhommes cetelem absolument
partout et pour autant personne ne parle
vraiment d'écologie il ya à l'instant et
yannick jadot qui c'est qui qui
s'exprimait à colombes dans une espèce
de parodie de son élection 2022 qui
devront ils rêvent déjà
non il faut parler de projets de
contenus et de vraies préoccupations et
de mesures concrètes à mettre en place
quand je vois la mairie de bordeaux qui
gagne et sans gratuité des services
publics avec des propositions qui sont
des propositions à nouveau sibylline et
de la novlangue
c'est inquiétant c'est inquiétant donc
il faut constituer je suis complètement
corps avec ndiaga diop il faut
constituer absolument débloquer des
alliances autour de projets concrets et
pas autour d'individus au d'étiquettes
les étiquettes n'a aucun sens les
étiquettes ne sert qu'à rassembler sur
des projets de contenus qui sont écrit
collectivement c'est une vague citoyenne
qui s'est exprimée par par son refus de
voter et ceux qui sont votées par
l'accession à la mairie de liste
citoyenne
c'est une première en france donc il
faut absolument pousser ses listes
citoyenne créé des process politique
autour
et surtout arrêter de communiquer sur
les individus il faut sortir de ce
schéma mais y compris médiatiquement il
faut absolument qu'on sait qu'en ce
concept con qu'on s'abstienne de
personnaliser de cette façon dans la vie
politique il faut remettre sur le débat
avec les français des mesures et des
projets de société
quelle société votons comment peut-on
vivre ensemble c'est ça qui compte et
qui est important et comment on répond
aux grands enjeux qui nous dépassent
nationalement les grands enjeux
internationaux qui sont elles
redistribution et l'écologie merci à
vous lui donnez de l'hydraulique de
l'air je rappelle que vous êtes expert
en communication et merci à vous
également
dieynaba diop porte parole du parti
socialiste d'avoir était avec nous ce
soir pour ce second tour des élections
municipales à stéphane rozès politologue
et président de cap conseil analyse et
perspective nous a également rejoint
pour décrypter ces résultats ces
résultats je vous le rappelle marquée
notamment par un très fort taux
d'abstention stéphane rozès bonjour
bonjour effectivement oui très fort taux
d'abstention pardon excusez moi on a eu
déjà l'occasion de l'évoquer ensemble
cela résulte de deux choses le premier
évidemment le contexte de la crise
sanitaire de la crise pandémie qui avait
déjà marqué une aube une augmentation de
l'abstention de 20 points lors du
premier tour auquel il faut rajouter
alors que nous sommes en plein
déconfinement le fait que ce scrutin a
été scindée en deux une élection
majoritaire à deux tours c'est un rite
républicain où il y à une unité de lieu
de temps et dangereux et au premier tour
bottes quant à sa préférence au second
tour on se rassemble et tout ça dans une
même dynamique
or cette dynamique qui a été interrompue
pendant trois mois
a fortiori par une crise qui fait que
les français citoyens dans leurs
municipalités ont reconsidéré un tout
petit peu les enjeux un peu différemment
donc l'élan du premier tour il devait
amener au second tour un ressaisissement
a été coupée d'où cette abstention
absolument historique et vous l'analysez
également par la peur du virus ont pas
je l'analyse en partie bien sûr par la
peur du virus mais surtout par le fait
au fond que alors même que les maires
sont les élus les plus populaires et
qu'avant le coc vide
les instituts de sondage montre et qui
aurait au moins une participation égale
à avants locaux vides à bousculer les
enjeux locaux et que maintenant les
français sont dans des inquiétudes
plutôt de nature nationale autour du
déconfinement et de la pleine conscience
qu'à la rentrée d'octobre nous allons
subir un choc économique et social très
dur ce qui fait que non pas au travers
de cette abstention
les français se détournent de la
démocratie locale de l'importance de
l'échelon municipal mais disons que
quelque chose s'est rompu dans le choix
même de faire un deuxième tour
déconnecté du premier tour et de le
faire maintenant ça a été décidée parce
que le président lacombe tout de suite
maintenant passer à autre chose pour
mettre en oeuvre son nouveau chemin s'il
a annoncé comme valant pour plusieurs
années mettre en place un beau
gouvernement au travers de son
remaniement
stéphane rozès un pari manqué on peut le
dire ce soir pour la république en
marche
perspectives pour le parti présidentiel
maintenant selon vous c'est d'un pari
manqué il fallait s'y attendre
au fur et à mesure des élections
municipales des enjeux locaux faisaient
plus nous évidemment commentateurs
nationaux on a tendance à voir les
municipales en voyant ça de haut
mais les motivations de vote étaient
bien des modifications très local d'une
part et d'autre part les les têtes de
listes ayant vocation à devenir les
futures mères la personnalité
l'incarnation de ses têtes de listes
jouer plus que le projet et a fortiori
le programme ce qui fait qu'en se
présentant devant les électeurs
maintenant sur le platt les plateaux
télé leysin les autos commente en
mettant en avant leurs étiquettes au
plan national mais au plan local c'est
pas du tout ce qui s'est fait au plan
local où on a mis en avant le projet
municipal la personne de la tête de
liste son projet sa personne et on a mis
très discrètement les étiquettes dont
tout ça pour dire qu'il n'était pas aisé
pour une formation
arrivant avec essentiellement des cadres
issus de la société civile de pouvoir si
rapidement s'impliquer et c'était
l'erreur d'emmanuel macron et de la
république en marche que de décliner au
plan des municipalités ce qu'avait été
les scores à la présidentielle à la
législative et même aux européennes donc
en un mot ces élections ont été nos haïk
de situations locales il était bien
présomptueux de la part du président et
la république en marche que de croire
que il a l'air je dirais faire bonne
figure où s'implanter ça n'a pas été le
cas
c'était de toute façon dans un contexte
difficile de très grande défiance au
plan national
garde l'exécutif après les chez les
jaunes après la réforme des retraites
après le début de la crise du golfe qui
montrait l'impréparation des gouvernants
l impéritie de l'état même si au moment
dé confinement et choses sont allées et
les mieux mais c'était très présomptueux
de la part de la république en marche
d'annoncer dès le départ qu il allait
décliner au plan initial des femmes
avant taxes priorité au direct on à
rachida dati qui va s'exprimer de son qg
de campagne et on reparle de ces
élections évidemment avec vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous avant toute
chose je souhaite et je voudrais
féliciter
anne hidalgo pour son élection je
voulais aussi remercié les parisiens qui
nous ont fait confiance
en accordant 47,4 points à anne hidalgo
36,8 % pour nos listes et 13% pour agnès
buzyn cette campagne
[Applaudissements]
cette campagne je les aborder comme
j'aborde la vie avec authenticité avec
enthousiasme avec passion avec le refus
de la fatalité et de toute forme de
déterminisme jeu les mener dans la
clarté
je les mener dans la constance sans
renier mon histoire ni trahir mes
convictions j'ai mis mon énergie à
convaincre les parisiennes et parisiens
quand tant d'autres me demandait de
convaincre les appareils j'ai emmené
avec moi toute une nouvelle génération
qui avait l'envi et l'énergie de changer
paris j'ai ainsi rompu avec les haines
les rancoeurs les divisions qui ont
affaibli et fait perdre la droite
parisienne depuis 2001 nous sommes allés
partout nous sommes allés voir ce que
plus personne ne va voir
nous sommes allés voir ceux qui ne
votent plus ceux qui ne croient plus en
la politique
ceux qui ont abandonné à force d'être
abandonné ensemble avec tous mes
colistiers nous avons redressé la droite
à paris
nous n'avons pas rendu vie à un parent
ti nous avons rendu vie à des valeurs
nous n'avons pas rendu vie à une ligne
nous avons rendu vie à une espérance
nous avons pris des engagements avec les
parisiens
nous les tiendrons je félicite jean
pierre lecoq florence berthou jeanne de
serre agnès evren philippe goujon
francis szpiner et geoffroy boulard qui
sont élus maires ce soir mais je
souhaite aussi félicité avec autant de
force tous les colistiers qui ont obtenu
de nombreux sièges d'opposition dans des
arrondissements où la droite avait
disparu depuis des années j'y vois la
confirmation que quand on est dans la
proximité
il est possible de regagner la confiance
des citoyens
je remercie profondément tous ces
parisiennes toutes ces parisiennes tous
ces parisiens qui nous ont accordé leur
confiance
le scrutin de ce soir est marqué par une
abstention inédite pour un scrutin manie
municipales à paris
mais ce soir je ne pleurerai pas avec le
choeur des pleureuses
car cette abstention n'est pas la faute
des français elle est de la
responsabilité de ceux qui nous
gouvernent de ceux qui ont gouverné
localement et nationalement
j'irai même plus loin
cette abstention ce soir sont ceux là
même qui se complaisent dans cette
situation qui leur permet si souvent
d'état cite réélection d'année en année
nous nous battons nous battons des
records d'abstention sans qu'aucune
volonté de changement de s'exprimer
alors je vais vous dire cette abstention
ne me décourage pas bien au contraire
elle me conforte dans mon engagement
politique et ma détermination à agir car
se rejettent du vote conduit à ce qu'une
part croissante de français ne s'exprime
plus dans les urnes il s'exprime par les
manifestations
les affrontements les contestations
c'est un cocktail dangereux
qui nécessitent une réaction forte de
l'autorité une défense sans concession
sans faiblesse des valeurs de la
république et de ses principes
si le politique ne fait pas très
rapidement la démonstration de sa
capacité à réduire les fractures
c'est la nation même qui peut être en
danger j'ai toujours été dans l'action
j'ai toujours été dans la proximité
je n'ajouterai pas de l'écoeurement à
l'écoeurement
nous ne serons pas de ceux qui tournent
le dos à ceux qui nous ont élus mais
candidat élu ce dimanche resteront aux
côtés des parisiens au quotidien dans
tous les arrondissements
le changement était possible à paris la
république en marche a préféré la
victoire d'anne hidalgo dont elle avait
pourtant critiqué le bilan pendant des
mois
le score de ce soir ne donne pas la
majorité absolue à la maire sortante
nous avions enclencher une dynamique la
dynamique du changement
mais cette stratégie d' échec individuel
d'agnès busan a découragé déstabiliser
et démobilisés de notre très nombreux
électeurs
ce soir je veux dire à tous les
parisiens qui ont voté pour mais liste
ce qu'il représente au conseil de paris
nous n'étions qu'à peine 25 élus au
conseil de paris au début de la campagne
nous serons à l'issue de cette élection
plus de 60
[Applaudissements]
les mois de campagne nous ont permis de
montrer ce que pouvait être la droite
quand elle parle à tous les électeurs à
tous les quartiers à toutes les familles
cette droite là qui sait écouter qui ne
se renie pas qui affirme ses valeurs ses
droites là peut à nouveau incarner une
espérance
c'est ce visage de la droite que nous
continuerons à un rassemblement à porter
avec toute notre énergie et toute notre
détermination sur nes 8% des voix donc
estimations pour rachida dati qui arrive
donc derrière anne hidalgo la maire de
paris vers sortante nouvelle fois élu
maire de paris on va tout de suite
retrouvé boulevard sébastopol au qg de
campagne de rachida dati justement notre
reporter mona amoudé là
un mot n'a alors qu'elle
l'ambiance quelle est l'atmosphère sur
place au au qg de rachida dati après
cette prise de parole on a ressenti de
l'émotion dans sa voix
alors malgré la défaite de rachida dati
on a quand même senti l'émotion beaucoup
de ferveur et de la solidarité ici
devant le qg de rachida dati sa famille
était venue on a pu apercevoir ses
soeurs également quelques sympathisants
ils étaient tous ici juste devant cette
vitre la vitre du qg de rachida dati
beaucoup de journalistes l'attendait
elle est arrivé assez tard elle s'est
fait attendre en tout cas elle est
arrivée aux alentours de 22h45 en tout
cas et beaucoup de gens disent était
juste là on a attendu pendant plusieurs
heures ici pour connaître quelle serait
sa réaction
le score ne donne pas la victoire à anne
hidalgo ce sont ses propos car il y a
une grande abstention 64 % seulement à
paris rachida dati jeunes rappelle est
arrivé en seconde position loin derrière
anne hidalgo qui est arrivé avec 50 de
50,2 pour cent il ya cette défaite
écrasante aide agnès buzyn avec 16% ces
chiffres sont susceptibles de changer à
rachida dati elle incarne et de quelque
sorte l espoir des républicains alors
elle n'a peut être pas gagné
la mer la mairie de paris quoi qu'il en
soit elle est a été réélu au premier
tour 2 du 7e arrondissement de paris ces
municipales elle était un enjeu
important pour la droite les
républicains surtout c'était une manière
de faire un remous politiques de revenir
sur cette scène politique même si
christian jacob a évoqué une victoire
ils étaient plutôt confiants et assez
rassurant en tout cas il y à une des
hill qui a été perdu par les
républicains c'est la cité phocéenne
c'est marseille qui a été remporté par
michel rue bories là avec 39,9 % des
voix merci beaucoup mona mon amour en
direct du qg de campagne de rachida dati
à paris et on continue le décryptage de
ces cette élection ce second tour des
élections municipales élection inédite
après une crise sanitaire d'ampleur
second tour qui a eu lieu trois mois
après le premier on rejoint jean
philippe dugoin clément un vice
président de la région ile de france en
charge de l'écologie du développement
durable et de l'aménagement urbain
bonsoir merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
sur rt france on a vu la défaite de
rachida dati ce soir est ce que paris a
choisi l'écologie selon vous monfort non
je crois que paris a fait un choix par
défaut la réalité c'est que in hidalgo a
été élu avec moins de 50% des voix en
bénéficiant et bien de la division en
bénéficiant du fait que madame but sain
et choisit de maintenir une candidature
qui ne pouvaient plus permettre de
gagner mais uniquement de maintenir anne
hidalgo en fonction avec tout ce que
nous subissons en ile de france depuis
des années avec une ville de paris qui
fonctionnent en autarcie complet après
on constate globalement par rapport aux
municipales de 2014 où les curseurs est
allé extrêmement loin avec une vague de
centre droit et de droite extrêmement
élevé que le curseur reviens petit peu
en arrière ce qui bénéficie aussi à
madame hidalgo ont refait le point
également avec vous avec vous par dont
stéphane rozès compenser vous est ce que
le le paysage politique est redessiné ce
soir après ces élections municipales on
a vu la multiplicité des délices dans
certaines communes les partis
traditionnels qui finalement ne sont pas
enterrés comme on aurait pu le croire
lors des élections européennes comment
est-ce que vous analysez ce paysage
politique ce soir en fait comme jamais
ces municipales de ce sont quand même
des roulés dans le contexte très
particulier qui a cassé la dynamique de
premier tour mais néant
avec des motivations de vote très très
locale si on prend paris les études
menées durant les municipales montrait
une aspiration à trouver les bons
équilibres pour les parisiens entre une
vie quotidienne et puis le dynamique de
la métropole qui semblait peu à peu
échappé au parisien et là puisqu'on
parlait des questions d'écologie
l'écologie est devenue un support ici
comme ailleurs au fond à l'idée qu'il
pourrait y avoir un autre type de
développement plus soucieux de
l'harmonie du quotidien de la vie
quotidienne pour essayer de tenir
ensemble
l'attractivité économique le
développement économique d'une grande
métropole et un quotidien des parisiens
qui devient de plus en plus difficile et
la halle hidalgo partait avec un bilan
très médiocres voire mauvais quand on
compare les bilans a estimé avec
d'autres villes et même où départ 60 %
des parisiens qui ne souhaitait pas sa
réélection mais au fond comme par
exemple durant le comic la mère anne
hidalgo a trouvé assez preuve de
dynamisme et a bien occupé sa fonction
de maire durant cette crise et surtout
ça a été dit
parce que ceux qui aspiraient à un autre
type de projet à un autre type
d'équipement municipales n'ont pas
réussi à se mettre d'accord en terme au
projet politiquement au fond anne
hidalgo repasse mais le défi pour elle
va être de réussir maintenant et demain
sauf on n a pas vraiment réussi durant
son précédent mandat donc ça veut dire
pour elle une réinvention nécessaire
elle a annoncé que les équipes étaient
renouvelées mais va falloir aussi
renouveler son projet mais pour répondre
à votre question de nature plus générale
nous commentateurs on a tendance à
nationaliser ces municipales mais dans
la réalité ces municipales ne sont
qu'une mosaïque de situations locales
très différentes et les nez de l'eau
contexte national hormis locaux vides et
la coupure du scrutin deux qui a
complètement rendu atone la dynamique
attendue de la municipale mais pour le
reste les gens ne se sont pas déterminé
de façon substantielle sur des question
d'étiquette nationale
ils ont regardé leur situation locale et
ils ont comparé les projets et lycées
peut-il alors vous restez avec nous
stéphane rozès on va parler de ces
étiquettes ainsi particulière à ce
scrutin local mais avant cela on fait un
point sur la percée écologiste avec avec
vous thomas bonnin mais les verts qui
gagnent un certain nombre de villes
après ce second tour des élections
municipales il convient toutefois de
rappeler l'abstention particulièrement
élevés notamment dans les grandes villes
là où les verts réalisent de bons scores
mais on pense tout de suite d'abord à la
ville de bordeaux parce que c'était est
loin d'être acquis et pierre remy qui
est en tête se revendiquent la victoire
ce soir devant nicolas florian le maire
sortant qui avait succédé à alain juppé
qui avait bénéficié du ralliement du
candidat de la république en marche et
bien malgré ces vents contraires et bien
pierre hurmic fini en tête ce soir c'est
également le cas à lyon où grégory douce
et devance la plus largement
cucherat c'était là encore loin d'être
gagnée pour le candidat écologiste et
finalement les verts qui il remporte
également la ville de marseille puisque
c'est michel ribeiro là qui l'emportent
et michel rubio la a certes constitué
une alliance de la gauche mais elle a
également un versant très écologiste est
donc allé tenter de ce soir on notera
également la réélection d'eric piola à
grenoble il a revendiqué la victoire ce
soir et puis à strasbourg où là encore
c'était loin d'être acquis jeanne barre
ses clients arrivent en tête devant le
candidat de la république en marche et
c'était loin d'être gagné pour
pour les verts qui réalise donc une
percée yannick jadot s'est évidemment
félicité de ces très bons résultats à
l'échelle nationale en tout cas dans les
grandes villes c'est la tendance dans
les grandes villes il convient quand
même de nuancer le vote dans les grandes
villes et dans les villes de moyenne et
de petite taille mais dans les grandes
villes est bien l europe ecologie les
verts s'en sort largement vainqueur
merci thomas bonnin et cette poussée
vers pendant qu'on continue d'en parler
avec vous jean philippe dugoin clément
je vous êtes vice-président de la région
ile-de-france alors finalement quel
signe 7 7 pouces et des écologistes ce
soir est ce que ça va amener les parties
un peu plus traditionnels notamment à
droite à se réinventer sur cette
question-là de l'écologie moi je moi je
souhaite lui d y est un parti celui dont
je fais partie qui porte ces valeurs au
sein de la région ile-de-france avec
valérie pécresse
nous avons mis en place un programme de
transition environnementale extrêmement
puissant c'est plus de 10 milliards
d'euros que nous investissons nous avons
dès cette année investi 2 milliards
d'euros plus d'un euro sur deux dépensés
en ile de france et un euro consacrée à
la transition environnementale mais moi
je pense que aujourd'hui l'écologie doit
devenir une priorité pour l'ensemble des
partis politiques pour l'ensemble des
formations politiques et ne pas être
cantonné à un parti qui est aujourd'hui
un parti extrêmement à gauche qui a une
vision extrêmement dogmatique de
l'environnement et/ou d'ailleurs on va
voir la façon dont ils sont amenés à
gérer les communes qu'ils prennent mais
va y avoir la question de la preuve par
l'exemple et moi j'attends aujourd'hui
que ces questions environnementales
elles soient prises à bras le corps par
les partis traditionnels
je fais partie de ceux dans les
délégations qui
sont les miennes qui pousse sur ces
sujets là mais nous avons des enjeux
majeurs la problématique de la peur de
fin de monde les problématiques de
marche pour le climat que nous avions
connus avant la crise du coc vide bien
ne se sont pas envolés les
problématiques de pollution de l'air qui
chaque année en france tue plus que le
covin elles ne se sont pas envolés les
problématiques de transition énergétique
qui font que notre pays est complètement
dépendant énergétiquement ces sujets là
ne se sont pas envolées donc je crois
qu'on a un champ entier à devoir
travailler à devoir investiguer et que
ça va être le sujet des mois et des
années qui viennent après on constate
quand même sur cette élection alors
effectivement stéphane rozès le disait
beaucoup de facteurs locaux avec des
effets parfois amortisseurs ou des
effets qui peuvent aggraver ou renforcer
une dynamique mais on constate surtout
que la gauche s'est resserré sur ses
valeurs s'est resserré sur des valeurs
de gauche traditionnelle de gauche un
peu moins social démocrate et que la
faiblesse du parti socialiste fait que
celle europe ecologie les verts qui tire
la martingale et qui est faiseur de deux
victoires selon-vous europe ecologie les
verts pour le parti socialiste en
l'occurrence je vous pose une deuxième
question dans la foulée le parti
présidentiel à emmanuel macron en
l'occurrence veut se repositionner aussi
sur le monde d'après cette question de
l'écologie vous le croyez vaut mieux
qu'ils se positionnent sur le monde est
d'après que le monde d'aujourd'hui ce
que le monde d'aujourd'hui c'est une
défaite que milan n'a jamais eu pour un
parti présidentiel sur des municipales
enfin on est sur un parti présidentiel
qui perd les quelques grandes villes
qu'ils avaient et qu'il ne craint plus
le parent ce qu'on constate aujourd'hui
c'est que le parti du président de la
république quel que soit sont ces
possibilités son destin national en 2022
n'a absolument pas mailler le territoire
français et qu'on est sur une france qui
est complètement coupée en deux entre un
état d'un côté et des réalités
territoriales on a le coeur municipal
mais on va le voir également l'année
prochaine si des élections ne seront pas
repoussées au départemental et aux
régionales et le président de la
république
effectivement aujourd'hui intérêt à
tirer très vite un trait là dessus parce
que ces objectifs
il ment un vote sanction absolument
terrible ce soit merci jean philippe
dugoin clément vous restez avec nous on
va s'arrêter sur cette victoire du
premier ministre edouard philippe
vainqueur au havre le premier ministre
candidat sans étiquette à la mairie du
havre a remporté les élections
municipales avec 58 83% des voix face au
député pcf jean-paul lecoq selon les
premières estimations le taux
d'abstention a été de 58 % dans cette
ville portuaire qui avait basculé à
droite en 1995 après trois décennies de
maires pcf on va saluer l'engagement de
tous ceux qui ont été candidats au havre
ou ailleurs et je voudrais d'ailleurs
félicité très sincèrement mon adversaire
jean paul lecoq
je n'ai pas
évidemment d'accord avec ses convictions
mais je les respecte comme je le
respecte lui et je voudrais saluer tous
ceux qui en france se sont engagés quels
que soient leurs idées pour essayer de
les faire valoir
démocratiquement et permettez moi
d'insister sur ce démocratiquement
encore une fois en france les choix sont
faits par ceux qui se déplacent pour
aller voter et ceux qui sont élus
doivent ensuite avoir la charge de
conduire les affaires publiques
ouais le voir un film donc élue maire du
havre stéphane rozès je rappelle que
vous êtes politologue et président de
cap conseils analyses et perspectives
vous couvrez avec nous ce second tour
des élections municipales alors on l'a
vu edouard philippe qui s'est présenté
sans étiquette ce soir qu'est ce que ça
révèle ça révèle un tout petit peu ce
qu'on s'est dit c'est à dire que les
personnalités locales n'ont pas
concrètement mis comme autrefois en
avant des étiquettes nationale
d'autre part il y avait une forme de
prudence pour le premier ministre
c'était une façon de dire que son
ancrage au havre devait prévaloir sur sa
gestion gouvernementale dans un moment
où un an après l'élection d' emmanuel
macron les choses ont commencé à se
dégoûter fortement entre l'exécutif et
le pays
donc c'était une façon pour edward
physique de mener une campagne avec une
attitude total sur des thèmes du havre
russe na et dans le prolongement le
premier ministre edouard philippe pons
aux fonds gérés gouverner les hommes à
wavre en prenant compte une culture
locale très particulière très marquée
par une histoire ouvrière et on a bien
vu dans l'hommage rendu par le maire
nouvellement élu à son adversaire
sénateurs communistes 1 il ya forcément
comme dans toute finale
au climat donc on connaît bien les
situations locales
quand on connaît bien la vie politique
locale
on sait à quel point chaque candidat
fusse-t-il premier ministre doit partir
de façon immanente des situations
locales
alors oui pardon qu'est-ce que sa
victoire révèle selon vous on sait qu'il
ya des dissensions avec le président de
la république pendant cette crise il ya
eu quelques quelques tensions entre
matignon et l'elysée on sait qu'il est
sur la sellette peut être avec un
remaniement annoncé pour peut-être la
semaine prochaine sa victoire ça va être
compliqué pour un emmanuel macron d' de
le mettre de côté d'or philippe selon
vous ça va être un peu plus compliqué
pendant le déconfinement le premier
ministre attirer plus parti que le
président de la de du de l'assortiment
des français pourquoi parce que le
président était sur un registre très
idéelle trait sur le souhaitent un b le
premier ministre semblait lui être au
cul proche des préoccupations
quotidiennes des français et donc les
français au travers des sondages ont
envoyé une adresse au président pour que
ça soit lui qui soit on tente de la
cohérence entre ce qui a été dit et ce
qui était fait et là au fond edouard
fini par occulter un peu la fonction
cabas en son temps françois fillon au
moment nicolas sarkozy c'est à dire que
au travers des sondages les les français
créditent un premier ministre qui a une
posture qui sont plus adaptées pour
envoyer en fait des messages aux au
président ça c'est la première chose
la deuxième chose c'est pelé sondage
réalisé ce soir par certains instituts
montre que des français souhaiteraient
le maintien des doigts fini et en même
temps vous très très massives - un
remaniement alors là il ya une île là il
ya une vraie difficulté parce que le
président a annoncé un nouveau
main sur plusieurs années d'ailleurs
enjambant la présidentielle il semble
mettre en avant la souveraineté
nationale l'indépendance
bref un retour à des orientations plus
néo bonapartiste de là où réellement à
la tête de l'état edouard philippe
représentait plus une droite orléaniste
celle des comptes
le logiciel juppéiste que l'on connaît
bien et donc ryan difficulté pour le
président ces cas il ne peut pas dire
j'ouvre un nouveau chemin avec un
premier ministre qui même si sur le
style est plus apprécié par les français
sur le fond c'était lui qui durant les
gilet jaune ou la réforme des retraites
était le plus dans l'orthodoxie
traditionnel de la droite
les le plus en dissonance avec l'idée
que c'est la france qui décide
la souveraineté de la nation nonobstant
les contraintes de bruxelles des
contraintes européennes donc là le
président va devoir arbitrer et s'il
arbitre du point de vue de la ligne de
pente de la nation vers la souveraineté
alors logiquement il devrait trouver un
autre premier ministre edward finit donc
effectivement il ya un petit sujet on va
voir si au fond le président se
détermine en fonction de ce qu'il
comprend être les fondamentaux du pays
quant à la tente à l'égard d'un nouveau
gouvernement ou si au fond il regarde et
l'immédiateté du paysage politique des
sondages ça va être très intéressant de
voir au fond à partir de quels critères
ils se déterminent pour nous présenter
son beau chemin alors en tout cas jean
philippe dugoin et clément ce soir on
l'a constaté la marque la république en
marche très bien
cela n'a pas fonctionné comment est ce
que vous le comprenez comment est-ce que
vous l'expliquer tout simplement parce
qu une élection municipale ce n'est pas
une élection nationale et qu' on n'est
pas élu maire sur une étiquette
politique ou en tout cas pas seulement
et les candidats rennes ou de la
majorité qui ont été élus ils n'ont été
est-ce qu'ils avaient un ancrage local
c'est le cas d'edouard philippe c'est le
cas d'un certain nombre de ministres ou
secrétaires d'état on peut parler de
darmana ou d'autres mais de francs crise
terme et ceux qui ont été réélus ils
l'ont été du fait d'un ancrage local
pas à cause d'une marque et à la limite
la marque ici elle a plutôt joué comme
une sanction
elle a plutôt été pénalisantes parce
qu'il ya un certain nombre
d'incompréhensions on mesure bien le le
point de malaise qu'il peut y avoir
auprès d'un sa trempe de nos concitoyens
donc cette marque
outre le fait qu'elle ne poussait pas
elle était plutôt sur une logique de
gêner ou de ralentir on le voit bien
depuis les européennes entre le nombre
de délits de centre gauche de
centre-droit qui courait après des
demandes d'investiture et puis qui après
les avoir eus sont allés plutôt en
arrière de les cacher pour se
relocaliser
on mesure bien ce décalage là et puis il
ya je crois un autre sujet qui est un
sujet de fond on voit bien la poussée de
leur tour un petit peu de de la gauche
mais la poussée des questions
environnementales
moi je crois que le sujet majeur qui va
intéresser notre pays et qui va
intéresser les pays développés dans les
cinq six dix ans qui viennent
c'est le sujet de l'environnement c'est
le sujet de comment est ce qu'on a sur
une soutenabilité une pérennité au monde
dans lequel on vient dans lequel on vit
et la réalité c'est qu'aujourd'hui le
gouvernement
mais comme les gouvernements des grands
pays développés ne donne pas le
sentiment à leurs citoyens qu'ils
apportent des réponses à l'enjeu
environnemental à la hauteur de ce qui
est attendu
et je pense que le grand sujet
aujourd'hui ça va être de faire des
questions environnementales
la question prioritaire de montrer que
la ou les collectivités jc exil et
agissent extrêmement puissamment les
états sont également capables de le
faire
mais ne nous trompons pas de sujet c'est
pas le faire avec un environnement
punitive c'est pas le faire avec un
envieux
heureusement qu'ils soient une machine a
accentué la récession
c'est le fer avec une vision positive de
l'environnement avec une vision concrète
de l'environnement avec un environnement
qui peut réinvestir dans nos territoires
qui peut recréer de l'emploi et je crois
profondément profondément que l'enjeu du
président de la république et son
premier ministre quel qu'il soit dans
les mois qui viennent ça sera s'ils
veulent avoir une pérennité au delà de
2022 d'être capable de donner des gages
mais dégage réel c'est pas de qu'on
aille au delà de la simple communication
vous savez les gens sont pas des idiots
ils veulent des actes ils veulent des
choses qui soient tangibles et ça sera
l'enjeu des années qui viennent
l'écologie donc priorité est évidemment
de cette élection on le voit bien
l abstention également qui est une
donnée clé thomas gonnet
comment est ce que on peut analyser ce
soir cette abstention tout cas ce qui
est sûr c'est qu'il faut analyser ces
abstentions on est à un taux de
participation du corps électoral 40%
c'est évidemment historiquement bas il
ya moins d'un électeur sur deux qui
étaient appelés aux urnes qui s'est
déplacé ce dimanche on est 20 points de
moins qu'au second tour des élections
municipales en 2014
mais ce qui est plus notable encore
c'est qu'on perd cinq points de
participation par rapport au premier
tour de ces élections municipales au
premier tour évidemment l'argument qui
était avancé c'était la situation
sanitaire qui a évidemment contraint ou
en tout cas qui a conduit beaucoup de
personnes à ne pas se déplacer pour ce
premier tour des élections municipales
mais le nombre de personnes qui se sont
déplacées a encore réduit entre les deux
tours un entre-deux tours qui aura duré
trois mois et demi et lorsqu'on
interroge les gens et c'est ce qu'a fait
l'ipso cependant cet entre-deux-tours
surtout interroge les gens sur les
raisons qui les ont poussés à ne pas
voter lors du premier tour et bien ils
ne sont pas majoritairement à dire que
l'argument prioritaire et l'argument de
la crise sanitaire il ya une forme de d
intérêt assez massif sur ces élections
municipales et d'ailleurs l'abstention
était déjà très haute pour les élections
européennes c'était l'an dernier alors
fait finalement certains expliquent que
la démographie du corps électoral aurait
pu être impacté par cette abstention
puisqu'on note par exemple qu'entre le
1er tour de 2014 et le premier tour de
2020 les personnes âgées de plus de 65
ans sont 35 points de moins à s'être
déplacés c'est la catégorie d'âge qui
s'est le moins déplacé avec tout ce que
là cela implique dans les résultats des
scrutins puisqu'évidemment selon les
tranches d'âge il y a des orientations
de vote différente en tout cas à
l'échelon national donc 60% d'abstention
sur l'échelle nationale on a dans
certaines villes les taux d'abstention
qui sont absolument gigantesque je vous
parlais de l'île 68% paris otsi aussi
qui est au-dessus de la moyenne
nationale 64% et à nantes les
estimations avancées en ce moment le
chiffre de 80% d'abstention c'est dire
si le scrutin était boudée par les
nantais ce soir c'est la préoccupation
principale d'ailleurs le président l'a
dit il se dit préoccupé par cette
abstention record de son côté jean luc
mélenchon parle d'une grève civique et
d'une insurrection froide et puis pour
d'autres c'est le cas par exemple de
nicolas dupont aignan et bien cette
faible participation bien cela remet en
cause la légitimité des personnes qui
ont été élus ce soir
merci beaucoup thomas pour toutes ces
précisions donc l'abstention historique
1 c'est l'une des informations bien
rendu de la soirée stéphane rozès me
tourne vers vous finalement cette
abstention à qui elle profite en fait
elles profitent réellement à personne
mais ça a été dit ça a été une
abstention différentiel pour des raisons
évidentes on peut on attend dont les
analyses plus précises par bureau de
vote mais faisons l'hypothèse que les
personnes âgées sont allés moins voté
par crainte de la pandémie et
dans kung la participation est faible ce
sont évidemment plus tôt les réseaux
militants qui ont le plus l'importance
et puis aussi les réflexes légitimistes
c'est à dire que le paysage mental des
français avec cette crise pandémique et
mathier tude pour le choc économique et
social qui vient c'est un des
représentations très déstabilisé les
français sont inquiets et donc là par
exemple vous citiez nantes forte
abstention et en même temps à nantes
le bilan municipal de la maire sortant
johanna rolland était vraiment très très
bon et donc tout le monde se disait sans
doute que sans problème
elle serait élu d'autant que la liste
europe écologie les verts par la
dynamique de la mer la soukouk donc il
ya eu un mix de réflexe légitimiste
favorisant les maires sortants a
fortiori quand c'était de mon maire ou
comme avait su durant la crise
duco vide 19 ans puce être actif et
positif c'est le cas de johanna rolland
ne valérie appéré c'était le cas
d'ailleurs à paris ou si pour anne
hidalgo donc en un mot cette abstention
a joué plutôt pour les maires sortants
qui avait de bons bilans des bilans
comptables juin à roland a été élu avec
60 % des voix mais ça cette abstention a
plutôt joué pour les électeurs l'epim
légitimiste et en même temps pas trop
âgés et ça a pénalisé des formations qui
fonctionne plus en ions lourds selon les
taux participation comme par exemple le
rassemblement le rassemblement national
mais par exemple sur paraît clairement
au premier tour c'est rachida dati qui a
été pénalisé par la crise d'hugo vie
parce que c'est pour elle que les écarts
étaient les plus importants entre les
dernières intentions de vote
et le vote au moment du coccyx et merci
beaucoup paris vous en parlions va
justement il y allez merci à vous
stéphane rozès un d'avoir partagé votre
analyse vos expertises ce soir en direct
sur arte france merci à vous également
jean philippe dugoin clément d'avoir
partagez vous aussi vos analyses sur
notre antenne rappelle que vous êtes
vice président de la région ile de
france en charge de l'écologie et on va
faire un tour à paris boulevard
sébastopol pour rejoindre notre reporter
au qg de campagne de rachida dati ce
soir on a à nous dès lors un rachat
rachida dati a fait un discours il ya
quelques minutes
les républicains qui finalement ont un
bilan en demi teinte pour ces
municipales avec un ancrage qui se
confirme et met quand même quelques
pertes de grandes villes
oui en effet à magali en tout cas ici au
qg de rage maladie tous l'attendaient
avec impatience des sympathisants à des
militants de la famille également et
surtout elle est journaliste aussi elle
est arrivé tout sourire sous les
applaudissements de ses de ses soutiens
elle et elle s'est engouffrée ensuite
dans son qg où elle a donné un discours
elle a quand même tenu à saluer agnès
buzyn et hidalgo elle a également parlé
de ses valeurs politiques je vous
propose de l'écouter
avant toute chose je souhaite et je
voudrais féliciter
anne hidalgo pour son élection je
voulais aussi remercié les parisiens qui
nous ont fait confiance
en accordant 47,4 points à anne hidalgo
36,8 % pour nos listes et 13% pour agnès
buzyn rachida dati n'a pas manqué de
mentionner l'abstention record
historique 64 % d'abstention de vote ici
à paris elle n'a pas manqué de le
mentionner également dans son discours
ecoutez-la la république en marche a
préféré la victoire d'anne hidalgo dont
elle avait pourtant critiqué le bilan
pendant des mois
le score de ce soir ne donne pas la
majorité absolue à la maire sortante
nous avions enclencher une dynamique la
dynamique du changement
mais cette stratégie d' échec individuel
d'agnès busan a découragé déstabiliser
et démobilisés de nos très nombreux
électeurs
malgré cette défaite de rachida dati est
quand même a eu un discours assez assez
positif puisque c'était également les
mots de christian jacob ce premier tour
avait été positif et puis ce second tour
a quand même été une victoire mais ceci
étant à marseille et cette ville qui est
depuis des décennies une ville de droite
est soudainement devenue une ville de
gauche avec michel rue burrill ruby
raulhac ils l'emportent avec 39,9 % des
voix rachida dati elle incarner un petit
peu l'espoir des républicains cet espoir
de peut-être revenir sur le devant de la
scène la politique après plusieurs
échecs notamment aux européens ou aux
élections présidentielles alors
peut-être qu'elle n'a pas gagné
l amérique paris mais en tout cas elle a
été réélue dès le premier tour dans son
arrondissement dans le 7e arrondissement
de paris si beaucoup voient là à nous
dès lors pour toutes ces précisions au
qg de campagne de rachida dati et
marseille on va en parler justement
effectivement paris à gauche lyon à
gauche mais aussi marseille et c'est
historique thomas 1995 c'était jean
claude gaudin le maire les républicains
qui était donc le maire de marseille et
bien désormais la nouvelle mère
s'appelle michel ruby rôle à elle
représente une union de la gauche est
elle récolterait ce soir selon les
estimations aux alentours de 40% des
voix et ses 10 points de plus que
martine vassal qui était celle ci est
censé succéder à jean paul bodin on
notera également le score de stéphane
ravier le candidat du rassemblement
national qui récolte aux alentours de
20% mais c'est évidemment un basculement
historique pour la cité phocéenne qui
repasse à gauche après plusieurs mandats
de jean claude gaudin oui et donc
l'abstention est historique et la ville
de marseille donc qui bascule
on va en parler justement avec hervé
mons son candidat europe écologie les
verts dans le 5e secteur de marseille
bonsoir merci d'être en direct avec nous
sur rt france votre réaction tout
d'abord à ce basculement de la ville de
marseille
c'est avant tout la victoire des
marseillais ce mouvement que vous
présentez comme un mouvement d'union de
la gauche est aussi un rassemblement des
citoyens et d'un ensemble de forces
politique humaniste et écologiste
et qui aujourd'hui représente un espoir
pour la ville parce que le projet qui a
été construit avec les avec les
marseillais les marseillais qu'on
construit avec tous et tous et tous ces
partis a aujourd'hui fait complètement
contrastent avec le bilan d'un quart de
siècle de mauvaise gestion de jean
claude gaudin et de son héritière
martine vassal qui vainquit père qui
perd avant tout parce que elle a joué
sur sur la peur parlant de chars russes
qui viendraient défilé sur la canebière
elle est ridiculisée et elle n'a pas
défendu correctement le n'a pas pu en
tout cas défendre correctement le bilan
de ce quart de siècle de mauvaise
gestion à l'état lui même jusqu'à
proposer un changement et a critiqué son
propre bilan
hervé man show il ya eu lieu également
dans l'antre de tout l'entré deux tours
qui a été bouleversé par l'ouverture
d'une enquête sur des soupçons de
fraudes aux procurations dans le camp
des républicains là encore est ce que ça
a pu jouer selon vous sur les résultats
sur deux ce soir
en fait ça fait des années que que tout
le monde parlait de c2c ces éléments qui
porta en tout cas qui interroge et qui
interroge maintenant la justice
par contre c'est la première fois où
nous réussissons à voir apparaître dans
les médias des éléments probants les
éléments suffisamment probants pour que
oui ça ait pu un petit peu influencer le
score du second budget du deuxième tour
qui néanmoins vient confirmer la bonne
dynamique qui était déjà engagée avant
la vente les affaires là au premier tour
vous parlez de bonne dynamique on peut
parler d'un printemps marseillais mais
aussi à noter là elle finalement le bon
score de la gauche pour ces élections
qui renaît en quelque sorte oui c'est
une renaissance c'est une renaissance
peut-être une renaissance de la gauche
mais encore une fois c'est une
renaissance d'un projet humaniste
sociale écologiste qui était fortement
attendue parce que les marseillais ne
pouvait plus de
devoir couper des arbres créer des
autoroutes urbaines voire les écoles
tomber en ruine voir la culture les
lieux de culture fermés et la pollution
augmente et avec en plus la pollution
des navires d'un tourisme de masse qui
qui n'a apporté 2 qui n'a pas apporté
grand chose en terme de en termes de
bénéfices pour les marseillais c'est
allé jusqu'à vendre des parts publiques
pour en faire des hôtels cinq étoiles
merci beaucoup hervé montchamp d'avoir
répondu à nos questions en direct sur rt
france je rappelle que vous êtes numéro
deux de la liste le printemps
marseillais et c'est la fin de cette
édition spéciale merci de nous avoir
suivis merci magali merci à vous olivier
et merci à vous thomas pour toutes ces
données que vous nous avez communiqué
tout au long de cette soirée c'est la
fin de cette édition spéciale élections
municipales on en reparle bien sûr dans
notre édition matinale à partir de 7
heures du matin heure de paris
je vous souhaite une excellente nuit sur
rt france bonsoir à tous
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
messahel imaginer la quantité de gens
qui tombent ici